[Applause]
this is one of our last shows in this
current iteration of the studio we're
changing it we're about to do a huge re
re ferb
redo reboot that's right next time you
tune in it'll be all new people we had
gigi gorgeous at our uh gigi gorgeous
the great gigi gorgeous um if you don't
know her google her
she came to our christmas party last
night i like your your sweater it looks
like you're on a fitness empire thank
you
i i might one day i know i look like um
i am you're a power lesbian who loves to
work out don't you think that i look
right now like serena
[Music]
apple cider vinegar but she's working
out now i feel like i um
could play the woman that invented lula
rose yeah yeah you haven't seen her no i
just mean like no i mean
yeah i feel like i could be a
uh mlm marketing
uh genius guru
from
um
sarasota in the 70s absolutely like
scandal i see that you know what i mean
like i feel like i like getting on a
flight to miami to give like a
motivational speech yes at the
scientologist
back from miami because you hit a bbl
what's your bbl
no one knew it no one knows everyone
knows what that is did you know yeah oh
that's impressive wow i know stuff you
know what else is impressive
impressions
impressive impressions is that the
ideology of it impressive
cause look here's the thing about
impressions
here's the thing this is the merriam
webster episode of the podcast jesus
this is there's a there's everything's
got their thing here's the thing
my i don't want to say what's the deal
with that's the paul poundstone version
again google it between googling gg
gorgeous and paula poundstone your
algorithm is about to go wow paul
poundstone with this shirt back you know
what
paula poundstone did blazers i do not
think paula would have fucked with that
i don't think she would have been it's
what i was she went to disney world or
something she might want to wear that
it's what i don't know if she went to a
hungarian rehab in the 70s maybe
or a leisure world
it's um uh
stay focused what is next impressions
so focus you have to
i'm in it but the problem is there's
just what it's four of us my brains
start to be like i get a lot of things
come and i have to just like it's like
um
like tennis you know when there's a
tennis machine
like i'm way too mad at everyone
there's just too many this is how you
play tennis well there's a microphone in
front of me
sorry grace well i don't i don't
specialize in making comically loud
noises while the podcast is going on
chris grace is going to have that job
later on in life where you make the
sounds for horror movies
yeah i'm training to be a foley artist
that's what they're called that's
hopeful
but don't do it to make the point either
you could describe it for audio
listeners whitney is wearing a green
velour
zip up
uh intense shoulder pads shirt with
shoulder pads and a highlighter
i am dressed
that lead down to a point at her belly
button i am dressed like a ukrainian
gymnastics
olympic gymnast
trainer from the 70s who absolutely
molested the girls it looks like the
first it looks like the first layer of a
barney costume get that out of the park
no
wait no that's the most accurate
description
remember baby bop yeah
and so
impressions
they
here's the thing i'm fascinated by
impressions because you know
we did impressions before on the show i
believe that we have a stable not
mentally stable so we have a stable of
talent here stout on the show say it
stout say say it say it live it work it
dream it believe it uh me being in the
weeds why isn't this just called in the
weeds
um
impressions so there's something in your
inner ear that makes you able to hear
other people it's like a genetic to be
able to hear it and then replicate it
and know how you sound melissa beast in
your houses
chloe feynman to be able to match us
like see mirror someone that
well yeah is um there was some like
article about how if you can do an
impression of someone there's a chance
you might have been related to them
interesting which is crazy crazy because
it is so hard to mimic someone else yes
yeah which is why i can do the the
cowardly line from with her boss so well
action
i'll give you a roof and a groove in the
ground
wasn't that good was that the line
though yes did you just re-write the
wizard of oz it is the line
smoke you out
smoke you out he wasn't he wasn't on
drugs i'm glad we're talking about this
because we have a big wizard of oz arc
in the upcoming show with fernand
hirschberg that we are gonna get into
which i did know
i'm just obsessed i'm obsessed with
impressions i'm obsessed with mimicking
mimicry i'm obsessed with um
making other people watch your hobbies
all the i'm so
yeah emotional knitting i'm obsessed
with all of the the wildly talent the
while the secret talents of um of these
of y'all
and we had impressions we did these a
while ago emily you had some impressions
i did you you did an impression of me
and then who else ruined our friendship
no way mine was nice oh really we'll see
it's braces we're not friends right
before christmas
just to lead us into my first uh
muse was dolly parton dolly parton's
your favorite she's my fave i love her
dolly parton is invincible she sends
books to every child in the country
anything on her under five years old
there's a rumor that she has uh her
hands i'm sorry tattoos arms are
completely tattooed what which is why
she wears those hand gloves
[Music]
her arms are completely tattooed that
would be so interesting i know
the most gangster shit i don't know but
also why hide them yeah well she wears a
wig every day
she wears a wig every single day why are
we
why she sleeps in makeup why because she
says what is what if the building
catches on fire she has to run out real
quick higher the hair closer to god
but let me ask you a question if someone
if a kardashian said that you'd hate
them no i wouldn't well you wouldn't be
like hell yeah
okay let's see emily noonan hi y'all
come on down to dollywood everybody
thinks i talked out nine to five by my
nails click clacking on the top rider
but really it was like this
this month for imagination library i'm
sending out this book i don't want
children to be unaware of red flags and
ancestral trauma why didn't you say the
name of the book in your impression she
holds up my book and doesn't say the
name of my book not free no free promo
that is like gotta pay for that
energy you didn't pay me i i'm not on
the ground
sponsored i stacked all my pads in my
bathroom placing them on top of one
another like playing a game of tetris
tweet it blog it retweet it screen grab
it is this dumb
i love when emily
dolly part would never doubt herself
that way jolene jolene jolene
can we afford that can we are we allowed
to sing less than 30 seconds okay great
can i afford it emotionally
well let's see she's not gonna take my
husband because no one's ever seen him
that's the other trick with impressions
okay so if you're not ex you know this
is a master i'm doing a master class
they haven't asked me but this is a
master class they're getting one which
is if you can't do a great impression of
someone because you're not
like you know genetically gifted i i was
i was getting to it
i
i can't use that because it gave me
source in my mouth
that wasn't what it was from
please stop moving paper as a joke
around the microphones jesus christ
is that uh
is that if you
said if you cannot do uh a perfectly
like an impeccable impression
because you have like a
the ability the uh very arcane ability
to hear you can do like good jokes that
is an excellent joke i love that you
shut this down to go so if you're really
bad impressions like emily is i'm just
saying look we're tick tockers i'm
talking to you if you can't do great
impressions because it seems like this
is everybody's career plan now listen to
auntie whitney
i'm i'm giving a master class and how to
do comedy on the tick tock and you can
just write great jokes
that was an excellent tick talkers
if impressions aren't your thing go on
tour
just write it down sell out theaters
you know what i'm saying don't ne if
you're not naturally don't have the
knack to mimic
perfectly just write great jokes and put
on a cowboy hat i don't know that much
about olivia rodrigo i'm excited i'm
happy for her
what
that's such a pr thing to say no it's
not pr i'm happy for her i'm glad i
don't know her whitney's like good for
you but i'm very happy by the way ben to
just put on sunglasses that's impressive
other people from a different generation
would know that the mariah carey me
so those people was for them olivia
rodrigo i love and
i just i'm curious i was thinking
i was thinking the other day my son has
a giant scar in it now there's carmen
olivia
olivia rodrigo
um who weren't happy for is i'm happy
for i am thank god i'm not a musician
because it's like yeah how could you
possibly
sing a song about being brokenhearted
about some guy 10 years ago because
that's what everyone wants to hear and
you're like i'm so over him the fact
that i ever cared about that guy is so
stupid how do you get back into
character yeah you have to sing it for
the rest of your life and people are
like play that one yeah
the fact that that idiot broke my heart
is so embarrassing and i have to get
back into it but what did you you told
me a story about elvis it's like
fascinating oh yeah elvis um he
his wife
like cheated on him with her karate
instructor
um and then so the song is
yup yup oh yeah oh yeah
the song are you feeling lonesome
tonight like every time he performed it
after he found out that she had cheated
on him he started breaking down laughing
like he couldn't get through the song
without just like like they couldn't
finish the song he would be laughing so
hard every single time he tried to play
it live
and it was just like this weird thing
like his brain just like broke like
something in his brain broke when he
came out that was like something so
funny about being if your elvis being
cheated on with like this the guy yes
that's getting that
honestly
how am i the person that thinks that
we can't say that
do not cut that emily doing olivia
rodrigo this is me mostly just imitating
her album cover which was her
with a bunch of stickers on her face and
her tongue okay so this looks like the
um billboard for the show yellow jackets
okay so here we go
these are all this is when the ring was
going to be accommodated
this is an ad for the nova ring when
they were going to do a collaboration
all right i have my long black hair and
i'm the album cover
emily kept gagging she kept getting shoe
gang the entire time emily has are these
little like stickers plastic gem
stickers in her mouth yeah
and try and gagging constantly do you
gag when you take pills oh yes yeah like
nyquil
did you gag when you brushed your teeth
yeah i remember i saw like city when she
was brushing her teeth kept gagging and
they were like what are you doing oh my
god
watching people almost puke is so funny
to me but there is a very serious thing
where if someone's about to so the
finale of the comeback
my number one best show ever made for me
personally
um lisa coochoo michael patrick king uh
the
the character valerie chair she has a
condition where if she sees someone else
puked she pukes i don't know what that's
called can you find out what that's
called it's like it's something where
you can't
what why is it why is this asking too
much it's just
like the one time she's here do you want
us doing that all the time like can you
just can we what are we gonna just talk
about a thing we don't know the name of
that's what you did there's a device
right here that'll give us the answer
i'm not gonna ask
see you guys get so stuck and like like
like hear my job description like what
anyone would do
i could ask anyone like hey can you
google that for me and they'd do it it's
like what who's supposed to do it just
whoever's closest i'm just rubbing the
beautiful earrings that um whitney got
me if you barf when you see barf
congrats you're empathetic
okay cause if you if you you're gonna
remember the empathy
hey can you google this everyone would
just do that what's the word
that's the only word you idiot
is the concept that i can't remember oh
empathy
uh
did i okay seeing smelling or hearing
someone else vomit can make you vomit
too your body's programmed this way
because if everyone in your group ate
the same thing
you could be next but what if nobody
else got sick and you're all alone you
could still have eaten something bad for
you so that makes sense like uh
they say you yawn
because whenever you something you see
someone yawning yuyon because
subconsciously you think they're taking
up all the air oh
that's when i ran i thought it was like
an emerald make sure i read that will
you look it up
well um emetophobia is an extreme fear
of vomiting seeing vomit watching other
people vomit or even feeling sick
so it could be a little bit of that
right it could be a touch of that but it
could be fucking gross straight guys
never have that fear um and uh also if
you if
yawning because it's contagious if you
don't if you on and someone else doesn't
they might be a psychopath oh my gosh
emily you are just
too much
the rest of this is just
oh my god watching you pull your skin
down gives me so much anxiety
how many times have i said when you put
on any practice or anything to your skin
you have to push up up always never pull
down on your skin emily all right
oh benton benton is doing a straight
white man
and go so
hey y'all y'all can see yesterday i went
down there the conversion therapy center
and i got myself some conversion therapy
as you can see i got these little tiny
lips
and i'm full of straight
also i bought me tickets to go see every
single
fight my man
i quit wearing glasses and contacts
because i ain't gay no more what am i
trying to look for dick
um quit bathing
because bathing square
also
uh quit referring to women by their
names and instead i just say i just say
slut
and somebody says what you want to drink
and i say i'm straight so i want a bear
and if you ask me about anything else
i'm going to take you outside
we're excited about that because i'm
straight now i've been working on eating
pussy so basically i just don't do it
all show up
so you ain't got a lot to say because
i'm straight if there's ever an opinion
i know it if ever there's an opinion
i know it
in here this wall right here this is the
last square thing i got this wall
i'm so straight now that whenever i see
my straight buddies we start hooking on
each other and then i hit him in the
balls and then we start wrestling around
and then we do some gay shit but it's
totally straight cause i'm straight and
we're all straight
hell no no no i i could have been the
professional quarterback of a new next
failed professional team i was working
so i didn't have no time my dick is huge
is that a truck
i love trucks
for dinner we're gonna have wings
i'm gonna kill the bird we eat
i got this little turnip dip
[Music]
bravo bravo
oh my god
unbelievable
like halfway through i'm like i fucked
that guy
my girl was like i did fuck that
oh wow benton benton
i don't even know what to say to you
right now it's stupid so good
wow there's an opinion there's an
opinion i don't know
okay so i'm very excited i know i'm
excited to see this too grace is june
from the handmaid's tale
my husband my daughter
i can't
believe
is
because you're so worried about that
yeah the kid you have yeah why would you
ever oh my god get out and then figure
out how to get the fucking kid remember
when miss pat was like she's just gonna
have to have another kiss
i think that one's gone
i'm saying like i don't ever want to
love something so much yeah yeah yeah i
can't leave but you wouldn't like
fleece why did you sign up for that it's
like it's a stupid thing to sign up for
i mean she's just
oh this is so mean
i'm
i am this is really blowing my mind
the faces
that is exactly
what she does
i have way too much botox to do this
impression
oh my god okay bravo thank you
incredible i love i love a like the
commit like that's the other thing if
you just commit hard enough it doesn't
even fucking matter yeah you boiled it
down the red like you were the reduction
to exactly what she is the entire show
like yes like the they're like yeah and
the eyes oh the eye oh the eyes great
it's like did you put makeup around your
eyes oh yeah yeah yeah i just took my
bronzer and i was like
rubbing it yeah oh my god that show
truly i know you're supposed to leave it
wanting
that show to give
women reproductive freedom it made me
just not like it
which is freedom reproduction yeah it's
very freeing okay okay well all right
this is going to hurt my feelings
i know there's no feelings in comedy
because that was also
yeah no i've i've only worked in comedy
as well for for 17 years so yeah sure
you're right for sure sure sure all
right so this is grace b i'm sorry you
consider snl comedy
hot tape
landshark does hold up this is grace
being our fearless leader
opening a june time
[Music]
good morning
if i change my hair color one more time
people are gonna think i went crazy
this camera angle
so
he's doing like 11.
okay i found this guy on the side of the
street can you get some dog food out of
the freezer and then can we put him in
the kennel next to mona
this oh so it turns out that the new
foster dog is not actually a dog
it is a rabid coyote
[Applause]
okay so the rescue dog turns out it's
not a dog what is
blood just calmly explaining right but
the reason it did that was because it
was scared and nervous and i was really
i'm scared it's my fault it was my fault
because it couldn't the county i was
like trying to help it
i've been helping dogs for 17 years
my face and um
i've got this
is it oozing again
look how cute this guy is oh one of his
paws doesn't work we have to keep him
[Music]
what happened here
so in the dark of night last night the
new new foster dog leads me out into the
news pack of wolves waiting for me um
they say hi white navy would like to
make you our leader and i said that's so
kind of you but i do have a call with
levity
that i'm gonna
i do cancel to go um and they did not
like that so they proceeded to tear all
the flesh from my arm um don't worry
about it um i talked to dr lancer and he
says he could just like laser over it
and um it's gonna look uh normal-ish
listen i know that i should probably get
rid of the new foster dog but i
scheduled a session with georgia she's
coming over in about 20 minutes and
she's going to sit down with me and the
dog and we're both going to talk about
it
so i think it's really going to be fine
mona
now mona
are you making fun of my sweater
you're you're making fun of this
gorgeous piece of clothing you're making
fun of this sweater okay okay let me put
it
i would like to give you an oscar thank
you so much audio purposes
great
god damn that was funny unbelievable you
know what's wrong it's like you do move
through life thinking like oh they
probably didn't notice that thing
you think you're like going through life
hiding your weird idiosyncrasies and
then when someone i think someone doing
an impression of you is like so cool
because you're like i'm not getting away
with that thing yeah yeah i thought i
was getting away with yeah i think like
what you want you once were like oh yeah
i do this thing with my eyes when like
somebody's talking and i like don't want
them to be talking anymore where you're
like yeah you have to like uh yeah yeah
you so try to make sure you want someone
to wrap up what they're saying yeah i
tried to master just like
act like your eyes are getting dry and
you're like trying to stay oh my god
that is literally the only face you make
when i let me
that's because i'm actually tired
okay so real quick uh real quick
four hours
uh 818 538 994 leave us christmas
episode voicemails we're doing a
christmas episode uh uh soon and i want
you guys to leave us voicemails and we
can play them good for you fans at
gmail.com email that so you know that
i'm a comedian hopefully by now uh we're
going to end the show and i do stand up
dates and it's just so embarrassing and
humiliating to have to say shit like
this but january 7th i'm in san diego
balboa theater uh eighth i'm in salt
lake city of january uh 8th 2022
come see us on tour whitneycummings.com
the touch me tour it's a real it's real
thrill unless oh marik the amarion gets
us
like touching unless the new variant's
going to get us i love you don't write
elephants
enjoy ran on hershberg oh my god this is
a wild episode what happens emily just
two seconds quick okay just two seconds
they talk about whitney has really
scorching hot takes on movies because
vernon has a podcast with joe list where
they watch movies and talk about them
and this is just a doozy so enjoy it
it's real it's a it's a it's like going
on a date with me and it's going poorly
buckle up
[Music]
ran in no he's here
ran
nan wait are you deliberately getting it
wrong
i just love the idea that when someone
has a complicated name
like run on yes that's it
ranan hershberg yes
and tell me why people panic about it
because i relate well they don't know
where to put the emphasis because it's
r-a-a-n-a-n so like is it
right and it's honestly it's either
because it's a hebrew name
and in hebrew they have this guttural
sound
and they don't have that in english so
you can't make i guess that's just
puking that's just acid reflux exactly
in english yeah so if you don't have
asphalt reflux or whatever you can't you
can't there's no like correct way to
pronounce it but it's interesting
because i will say
like
i'm sure most people that meet you
you said something once uh when we were
performing because we went on the road
together a little bit where you said
like
by the time someone is trying to figure
out what they just heard how to memorize
my first name they hear my last name and
they get thrown off yeah it just gets
juicier and juicier you think you're
like you think you're done after ra
annan it's like this long climb this
long jewy climb and you're like done and
then you look up there's even bigger
chewy mountain you have to go up
are you so thirsty what's that what is
it with the drinking water oh do you
need to get him do you need a minute i
know you new york comics you bring up
drinks on stage like it's you're up here
for 15 minutes how much water do you
need forget how you are so hyper aware
so we've been on the road together i
always ask people at the beginning of
the show are we friends so that you can
decide you can say what our real
relationship is so i'm this isn't a fake
bullshit interview yeah i mean we're
friendly we opened uh i opened for you
twice now and that's two weekends and
you know uh you have no sense of
boundaries so now we're best friends i
don't know it's so true
it is so true but yeah we're friends
yeah but i do feel like we vibed kind of
right away
for sure i feel like i can be authentic
in front of you
um and uh i also want to say just in
terms of you as a comic
you have the best kova joke i've heard
oh and the best me too joke oh thank you
thank you that's not a compliment i'm
angry i'm frustrated well i did a lot of
research in the me too movement and
choking
boots on the ground
i want to talk about your cover joke
because uh i am
annoyed by it i'm angered by it because
we've heard every cover joke every cover
joke's been tweeted every covey like and
you went up the first night i saw you
and you said to me kova and i was like
it's not like here we go it's just like
i'm curious to see
because it's very rare that you see like
a totally new fresh angle that
especially now with twitter and ig lives
and podcasts it's like we've heard so
many comedians attempt or make jokes
about certain things which is i had a
couple of covers which is which joke is
this now you're just bragging
incredibly original jokes and nobody
else has that made you laugh is this a
hypochondriac this is no this is the one
about the one that has no symptoms oh
right yeah well that is something i like
it's just a joke about like being a
hypochondriac during it the worst part
and there's this disease without
symptoms so every day last year i just
wake up and be like i feel great what if
it's coving
um i'm also just going to say since
we're we were kind of flirting with the
topic that i thought you were a good
flirty i was excited now that i'm just
flirting with him
um
you're
me too joe can i say it
yeah which one is this well it's just
that you just go like i feel like we
this was some it is so hard for me to
like laugh like
like i did like a spit take in baltimore
when you first did that you were like um
ironically i had roofied your drink
during the meeting
[Laughter]
it's a nightmare um
and uh
you you just i just heard you go like i
feel like we all owe pee wee herman and
apology all right right right i'm just
like damn it like
damn it right like he was jerking off
minding his own business in the back
paid money to go in the theater
yeah you should give a medal for doing
it correctly like a general he didn't
make anyone watch
the back of the theater like a gentleman
um and then uh hold on i wanted to talk
to you we have to talk about movies and
and benton i'm gonna have you come talk
about movies uh with us because
you are a
i was worried that we weren't going to
be able to become as good friends as i
would like to because you are a movie
buff movie uh yeah a real movie asshole
so what is that you're all like you have
a podcast about movies and every week
you guys watch a different movie and
talk about it right yeah it's a very
unique idea we're the first to do it
we we talked uh it's with joe list uh
great comic good friend of mine
hilarious one of the best i learned so
much watching him and he uh
he wanted to do like an offshoot thing
we did it one way there's certain movies
i just always thought were overrated
suck like force gump and goodwill
hunting and shit like that and uh i'm
shit like that whatever but like yeah i
just want to talk shit about those
movies that he like loves those movies
so we we did it once and it was people
liked it so we kept on doing see i'm
such an asshole about movies
what if in good will hunting that wasn't
robin williams would it is it a good
that good of a movie i mean i don't like
it with robin williams so why not
i mean to me that kind of movie is like
it's like made by a psychopath it's just
like it's just like
an actor looking like uh
i mean uh louis actually has an amazing
bit about this and um
he's been doing it lately but it is how
i feel too like matt damon is the actor
in the movie and he's making himself
into this amazing person who's a genius
who's like blue collar this is all in
louise bit but it is true it's like you
know you writing yourself as like
getting the girl and looking amazing
it's just self-mass mature and then to
them dated her afterwards yeah it all
just feels like that to me is like like
when we talked about comics getting late
to me everyone in the movie business is
just couldn't have the life they wanted
because they didn't have the personality
or
um desire or work ethic so they were
like let me just create the world i want
uh and then i get to cast the girl i get
to live this life i get to drive this
car it's like a bunch of nerds basically
going like i can't have this in real
life so i'm going to con a bunch of
people a bunch of girls that are way
hotter than me
yeah it's a masturbatory fantasy and to
me it's like it's like people tell
stories where they're always a hero in
the story that's funny it's like when i
tell a story i make myself look worse
that's like how i do it like and so
seeing like
seeing movies where people are just
writing a character where it's like it's
literally a movie about how he's gifted
enough to leave boston to make it it's
like embarrassing
it's like i'm gonna get out of boston
one day it's just like embarrassing
bullshit and like he's such a wait what
just straight white guys had to do to be
heroes in movies up until like 10 years
ago yeah i know it's insane
and then like robin williams saying it's
not your fault that like like just keep
on repeating that like it's just so i
always thought it'd be really funny
though if like your therapist one day
just started doing that like like
they're just like hey it's not your
fault
it's not your fault and you're like are
you just doing the scene from
i mean it kind of is because i need you
to keep coming back yeah i was like oh
shit exactly also therapy doesn't end
like they like he
like this idea that he like brings they
finally talks about something that
happened about the kid and he goes it's
not your fault he cries and he hugs
therapy doesn't end you're not just done
also he's like yeah you don't graduate
they're like and we're done here it's
that bullshit thing like dr phil like
they think if once you're aware of a
problem and you cry about it it's over
no being aware of the problems the
beginning of solving the problem and
usually it just
walks into the house and go like we have
water damage well that's all yeah
exactly
that's like i've always been aware of
the fucking problem it doesn't help yeah
it worse therapist yeah that's why i'm
here i know something's wrong it makes
it worse i actually think be aware of
the problem because like my favorite
like will try to like like you learn
about anxiety and a lot of times you're
anxious about shit
that is different than the thing it's
like a deeper worry yeah but knowing
that's not always great like my
therapist will say to me i'll be like
i'm worried i'm always anxious i'm gonna
miss flights and she's like well what
you're really worried about is that no
one will ever love you and i'm like i'd
rather
be worried about missing the flight
i can't go to the airport and be like go
to customer service i'm late because
you're like for what a meaningful
relationship
like what flight do you want it's not
about the flight i'm really stressed out
this is old yeah this is all this is all
yes it has nothing to do with you yeah
let me be fucking anxious about
turbulence you know what i mean
but then sometimes it's the opposite
where i'm like i'm not scared of
turbulence ever at all yeah you're like
i miss every flight it never bothers me
but sometimes the opposite way i'm like
really anxious about global warming but
really i'm just anxious because my mom
fact-shaped me when i was younger but
somehow it manifests to like being
worried about iceberg like the ice cream
get more woke points
for worrying about the iceberg but i'd
rather be worried about the fat champion
than the global warming you know and
this is going to be a segue into talking
about getting into movie nerd stuff but
um you remind me of anna mcdowell's
character in sex lives and video tape
remember in the beginning she's in
therapy and she's like there's just so
much garbage what are we going to do
with the garbage i always wanted to be
reminded of someone i used to jack off
to a lot so this is exciting
slice and videotape the coming story
[Music]
we now interrupt this program
of me and my friend ronan
rannon
run on emily what i mean like what is
his name ranan ranaan are you up yet
not your best nuts
has your alarm gone off yet
your alarm gone off yet or just the
biological one baby
i'm so hungover and you're being so
loud but i'm always loud and you're
always hungover i know but i just
thought if we had all this daily harvest
that we could like counteract the
negative things in our body with all
this there's a better segway
i knew that would kill you
i need brain food
don't you was that yourself i know i
knew it i knew it i knew that you're
saying that is that good now i'm up
you just turned into the scarecrow from
whether to bother my only had a brain
anyway jelly harvest bowls
i don't know if you know this
about me and deli harvest but deli
harvest delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbread smoothies and more all built
from organic
fruits and vegetables right to your door
and it conveniently stays fresh in your
freezer
okay
and emily over here what's your what's
your what's your what's your uh poison
my so to speak absolute favorite and we
don't have it here because i ate all of
them is the broccoli and cheese harvest
bowl
you know what daily harvest by the time
you eat one and then like you're like
i'm like i don't hate myself
and that's why i'm eating them all these
now because we're hungover and daily
harvest takes literally minutes to
prepare i feel like it'll undo all the
damage we do exactly oh we're hungover i
was just dressed like this
this is just my personality
they never use preservatives or added
sugars and there's no artificial
anything and that goes for everything
keep it simple during the holidays with
daily harvest
the only thing i think about me is this
leg go to dailyharvest.com good for you
to get up to 40 off your first box
that's dailyharvest.com good for you for
up to 40 off your first box
dailyharvest.com
good
for you and it is don't be an idiot like
truly don't be an idiot go change your
robes it's time to talk about
unravel emotionally and literally
oh no i want to pull some clips from the
opens the last couple opens
fighting about insurance
[Music]
and then i'd like to post the email
where i say i would like to cover a
hundred percent
you do cover 100 what are you mad i know
do you not like us no i love you i can't
do it i'm feeling so sad i love you i
just feel like there's a lot of
rumblings there's no rumblings all the
rumblings we do right here i just went
around a party and told everyone how
much how great you are i feel doubted i
feel doubted i feel underestimated
are you
can you imagine if i had the if can you
put in my calendar to read betsy's diary
does better help do group therapy i'm
actually not kidding
do we know they want it for this
betterhelp.com
we'll talk about it there it will help
you assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours
it's more affordable to stop making
noise it's more affordable than
traditional offline i've never heard joy
before she's like stop it and financial
aid is available this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp and is just a
coinky dink that uh my makeup otters
told me that she's using betterhelp.com
she was like i can text the uh therapist
anytime you're like can we move to
eleven can we do it tomorrow can we do
it now like can we do 15 minutes right
now like i'm having a moment and i need
to just like talk to someone that is
going to attune with me and not give me
horrible advice
and um
but here's my only call home
she was like i was like just
she's like open your heart to me and i'm
like like did you use my promo code like
she was like i tried to put in your
promo code it's just
it said who recommended you and under
celebrity you weren't there
where were you under patient i was under
pod
[Laughter]
please put you under mental health
monarch
uh what was i under podcast host
podcast host
it was yeah are those my choices
celebrity or podcast host you cannot
it was you
tim dylan
and uh
who
just a bunch of tick tock piercing they
were like this is where she fits like
what but you know what you've only been
doing podcasts for two years and it
feels like longer
and you've taken it by storm enough to
be in that category i guess so this
podcast is sponsored by better health
held together by better health good for
you listeners get 10 off their first
month of betterhelp.com nope
betterhelp.com whitney don't edit that
out because i am secure enough to let
you guys see me stutter and flub and
make mistakes on camera because i go to
better help and my self-esteem is on
point
she's texting someone right now about it
and
i'm also uh i'm not texting someone
because i'm not addicted to my phone
because i go to therapy and help me
break that addiction january 7th i'm in
san diego at the balboa theater how
about that san diego i love y'all you
know i do i'm uh going to come to salt
lake city
kingsbury hall come see me
come salt lake city last time we were
there i was in bad shape it was so fun
that was rough that was a rough one that
was a rough weekend uh salt lake city
come back it was fun though the covered
fog is over lifted january 15th we're in
las vegas
us i am so obsessed with las vegas the
quinn theater las vegas i love you i am
going to wear my best
my sunday best for january 15th so
overall anyway uh we now disrupt this
nonsense for more nonsense
okay so
couple things benton has flown in
so that we can talk about some movies so
cause i'm gonna have some hot takes
very hot takes but the way the first the
first thing i would like to do is the
movie aficionado um
uh is ask you because we talk a lot
about red flags on the show what is like
for a girl
what is a red flag in terms of their
favorite movies this is a great question
that's why i asked it and then also by
the way because i'll tell you real quick
to give you a second thing
i know you guys love fight club i know
and i think it's great but it should not
be in your dating app bio i don't think
i think it's one of the most overrated
movies ever i don't like fight club
what's the man's obsession with it why
do well i think i do think it's like
well yeah it's like that male anger but
i do think there's these movies that
like men like movies where there's a
mastermind plot where a guy
controls everything so it's like the
dark knight where the joker controls
everything or seven where kevin spacey
controls everything like the bible yeah
the bible
where god controls everything fight club
i mean obviously he's like there's that
weird um twist but still tyler durden is
controlling everything they like matt
and usual suspects kind of serve they
like the control of a guy in the movie
but i actually hate that kind of writing
because to me it's cheap because you're
having a character basically decide the
whole story so it's not organic yeah
yeah much easier right but is it voice
over or no
what was is is tyler jordan doing a
voiceover in that movie i don't remember
edward norton's doing the voiceover and
tyler jordan is edward norton so this is
where it's a little confusing but he's
still essentially tyler durden still
have she's just learned i haven't
finished it wait
i don't know if you're gonna ask this
question but what what movie do you like
i need i need to gauge what you like oh
to see okay got it interesting yeah
because i i think everybody picks and
likes movies for different reasons and i
want to understand where you're what you
like because we know what you don't like
let's know let's be able to where's your
north star so we know we're dealing with
um so i love
here's what i'll say how about this i'm
going to do a couple categories okay
because you can't answer favorite movie
what are we i love that it is tough
movies that the movies that you can
watch uh many many times and never get
sick of it i'll go first labyrinth three
amigos
um
footloose
which one
hey be serious sometimes people like the
other one and i liked um the good
dinosaur
oh i love that i never saw a good
well whitney won we're known
i saw the plane and cried my eyes out i
when i was five i watched jaws every
single day that might be why i have a
lot
it's all starting to come together my uh
my babysitter is a friend of mine uh he
said that i would watch it while crying
but i refuse to turn it off i was just
like give me the trouble i'll tell you
something people like wonder why our
generation has anxiety disorders we
watched old yeller jaws like we watched
movies very young
where the red fern grows like we would
watch the same movies our parents were
watching i remember watching my dad like
flinching like why am i watching isn't
it funny that every disney movie deals
with watching a parent get murdered wait
but what your favorites the ones that
you could watch over and over and over
again
that's a good way to gauge someone's
like yeah okay so some of my favorite
movies are not moving i would re-watch
over and over again but but i will say
the move that can re-watch uh
uh movies that you're like
no notes my favorite movie is nashville
by robert altman okay uh
but also um
i love uh i love sideways big lebowski
uh roma
um
uh
i love a lot of cone brothers movies
inside lou and davis i can tell you
we're not gonna have the same movie
taste but i don't know any of the things
you said i don't know any of those
movies i love sideways i love election
elections one of my favorites is known
about wine yeah yes it's so yeah i know
that from working on a movie at the uh
store i had people rented it a lot to me
that's one of them okay so you worked at
a movie store so you have that slash
channing
no i'm sorry say that one more time is
there a scene where someone's naked
running in it yeah yeah wait say again
where this was globalville tennessee
what was it called loboville video
in kentucky it was also a hair salon a
tanning salon we made trophies we did
floor arrangements we did embroideries
uh they coached little league out back
see i thought you met an la place
because that seems like such a hipster
thing to have four different things in
one venue oh no like a hair salon
look i'm not good at anything yeah yeah
but i'm kind of good at fortunately
there's a comedy show there
like we have this one building
so we have to make it work
so you love sideways and then what were
the other ones sideways is a great movie
but i but as someone that worked in a
video store i was just curious what were
the most rented movies oh anything about
a war like saving private i mean
so it's like you know saving private run
that's all i got that's too much
they just
really like favorite private rides
people know
yeah people would come in a lot and
they'd be like what has a lot of gun sex
and violence they would ask that a lot
what was your answer um
fucking saving
the craft is my favorite okay i love
junior first book by the way the first
or second
both
very good friends i feel like i could
have guessed both of those the crack i
love jennifer's body jennifer's body a
league of their own i think of the
perfect movie i know i already watched
that for the for my podcast it's a
wonderful movie you know what you're
right and let me ask you something
though having recently watched that is
one of the few movies that i feel like
it's interesting because tom hanks is
miscasting it's funny every time i watch
it it's funny tom hanks is miscasting it
i'm obsessed with and i have all these i
have a whole list of
uh who almost did like really iconic
roles in movies like who almost got
there hathaway was the ninth pick for
devil wears prada wow that's crazy that
seems like something meryl streep would
tell her in the movie
before we move on completely why i think
tom hanks is miscast i don't want people
watching this thinking
i feel like i said something that's like
very uh
it's but i wanted to just fully explain
why
i think tom hanks is an amazing actor
this is what happens when straight men
lie they they're they gesticulate more
and they hold their glasses you wear
these glasses yeah straight white
he's trying to look like he's got a
smarter take so he's holding his glasses
with straight white man i'm holding my
reading glasses while
like i look like i'm fiddling on the
roof right now this is why tom hanks
is miscast no tom hanks is a great actor
he's good in the movie but another actor
who just had a little more griminess to
him would have been a much funnier
choice in that movie there's a sweetness
to him that makes him less funny you
know who steals the fucking show as he
steals the show and everything john
lovitz is amazing in that fucking movie
he is one of the best when he
says he's gonna go john levitz is
amazing i'm gonna go home and get my
wife a pickle tickle
that's the last thing he says for you
don't see him anymore he is is every
slide he says is amazing when he would
that what you're gonna make me look like
an asshole when he is looking for that
woman who throws the ball really fast
you're breaking yeah yeah yeah he's like
oh she's great and then she shows her
face and she's unattractive and he
immediately goes he really goes
but then he looks again and he does two
double takes he goes oh and then he
looks again
and then he goes well let you know
i mean like the fact that you could do
that like
like in my short time making things
you could never cast over like hey the
joke is that you're uh
when they're at the when they're like
they're learning how to be women the
moon walks by and goes ugh a lot of
night games
but but i understand there's a lot of
jokes about ugliness but it's making
commentary about how this is how women
used to be judged for everything right
it's all like historically sort of
accurate river but even like i remember
when ugly betty happened like when that
show happened i remember being like
imagine getting a call from your agent
that's like hey straight offer we want
you to star on a show oh my god really
what's it called ugly betty like you're
just like
stupid bitch
can't imagine the message and a league
of their own was clear
at the end because part of there's no
crying in baseball like at the end i'm
just like so this movie is about if
you're a big brat like your sister you
just win stuff
but here's what i'll say this is where
we're really going
i don't think movie messages
are as impactful as
just stop right there because it's not
true okay go there's no you you think
that because because probably of being a
part of movies for song on television to
the rest of the world yeah that is the
news that is that is a glo that is how
you see the world it's how you learn how
to get on an airplane hell a taxi yes
border room service
it's how you learn everything but here's
what i'll say if you tell me
that the message of the league of their
own
is so toxic that it held you back in
your life you were never going anywhere
no i think that only positive message is
radiating in movies that way but i do
think that i just want to know if you
think that that's the message i agree
yes there's like the here's the i just
think that people blame movies too much
for their own personal failures as
either parents or human beings as
someone that feels like they were
disappointed over and over again because
they like grew up on romantic comedies
in disney movies and then like life
paled in comparison and then as someone
that that that has a
makes a modicum of stuff that people
consume now it's just sort of like
like we're just trying to make you laugh
why are you taking this shit so
seriously like why do you have to do
that like like we're trying to make
anyone that's making it and this is my
issue with people trashing movies or not
like moves no one signs up to make a bad
movie no one wakes up in the mornings
like i'm gonna make a bad movie i'm
gonna make something that's not fun
right no same with fashion no one wakes
up when you make fun of someone's
fashion no one's like i'm gonna dress
like shit today everyone thinks they
look good everyone's trying to make a
good movie so when when some nerd who
just wants love who just wants attention
who just wants to like put on a play and
make people laugh like like then people
go like well this is a toxic um message
it's like dude okay well the writer is
doing this to try to get the love from
their dad that never loved that like why
are you
uh what's going on with you that you
can't get messages anywhere else i think
it's just people that usually are upset
about stuff like that are people that
have been marginalized to begin with and
they've been so used to having to find
their self in a movie that has nothing
to do with them that's separate
the message is don't listen to hollywood
writers to get your messages these are a
bunch of people that weren't parented
properly that are running around just
like i want to like i was talking to a
friend of mine about this the other day
the idea of like because i have some
friends that are like oh we want to make
movies that right now like want to be
movie producers and not and usually when
you produce a movie it's like a side
effect of writing a movie and directing
a movie or doing like acting in a movie
they're like oh let me just produce it
because then i'll have more power the
idea of just being like it really is a
bunch of kids our five-year-old stuff is
going i want to put on a play that's all
this is
making television making doing stand-up
making movies is i want to put on a play
and i want everyone to look at me and i
want everyone to love me right that's
all we're doing so i just feel like
there's not enough people going like
when you guys analyze movies internalize
movies you're not taking into account
who's making it and how it gets made and
like that's nobody's intention is to
ruin the way you see yourself like
anyone that's making a movie or making a
tv show is just trying to make their
parents that fucking ignored them
love them it has nothing to do with you
like all this collaboration shouldn't
criticize movies because i like to like
i love you guys
like like if i see a movie i don't like
i'm just like that's not for me it's not
for me yeah yeah i think my main point
just as we go into criticizing a bunch
of movies i am always on the filmmaker
side because as someone that's made a
movie
most filmmakers are not happy with their
movies
the executive fucks it up you don't get
the dp you want you don't get the
costume you want most filmmakers are
settling and compromising every day that
they're making the movie so i just tend
to have like i think there should be a
rating system well i yeah i i have
noticed that joe is making a movie right
now and he's become a lot less harsh on
movies during our reviews he's like i
thought they did a really good job
when any critic wants to criticize tv or
movies i'm like great have you ever
tried to make one in the rain running
out of light first of all nine times out
of ten if like rotten tomatoes or any
kind of critic doesn't like something i
usually like that almost every time well
okay here's what i'll say i think that
when people watch movies they all assume
that every filmmaker is working with the
same amount of time the same budget the
same access to actors the same
post-production schedule etc i actually
think there should be a rating system
this is what drives me nuts about movies
is there's rpg and all that there should
be rating system you should know what
the budget was and how much time they
had so it's sort of like marvel they had
a hundred million dollars and 12 months
and seven months in post where they'll
suck which is like and then an indie
movie it's like okay they had eight
hundred thousand dollars they had 14
days they lost this actor two days
before like there should be a level of
difficulty rating as i think
that's like okay degree of difficulty
like oh this movie sucks but they made
it in five days it's pretty good for a
movie they made in five days right
do you care this much about tv as well
or just movies no i mean i like tv but i
i movies are the thing i care the most
about but i when i criticize movies that
i can be an asshole the movies i love i
love more than most people here's what
i'm saying i love intensely and so when
i criticize a movie it's me
it's only because i demand a lot from
movies but i think they're so important
don't ever say that on a first date and
i would never say that i've only said on
a podcast people listen i'd only have
[Applause]
because i'm about to be really hard on
movies okay because i am
actually also brutal about it so but
movies don't matter the most to me
because i
i think everything's fine like usually
when people are think i'm too harsh on
movies to me they're saying they don't
care that much about movies
it's just this i just feel like a lot of
people try to use movies to pretend like
they're more evolved than they are more
intelligent than they are more cultured
than they are more um
need less therapy than they need to or
think they're better than you so
that's true for all kinds i just never
watch a movie that i don't think i'm
already going to like
i never like sit down and be like what
let me just recommend me a movie like no
i don't i'm not wasting my time watching
that on the line i just i think it's
more at like the initial stages of
dating you go am i willing to pretend
that no country for old men
is the best movie ever made
or am i not
why and you know what
i'm harder on previews if the preview
doesn't get me fuck that movie i'm not
i'm not willing
just because i have the same haircut as
javier bardem in that movie
does not mean i am willing to go along
with this ruse
that no country for old men
is as good as all you guys think it is
and there it is lost all my subscribers
subscribe to renault's podcast instead
all your followers are real don't cut
you for old dead faces
because here's what i'll say i'm
obsessed with how
uh er like what a guy's favorite movie
is or girls i just don't know if about
it tells me everything i need to know
about them so when a guy what's your
favorite movie on a first date no
country for a man i go you have shit
with your dad
well everyone has shit with her dad but
like not me
why
is what do i say on a date when a guy
says no controversy best movie ever made
i just have to go true if that really is
no country the the movie that like
douchey guys say not douchey just
actually smart because it's a pretty
subtle like movie that's like you know
someone's calling by this person because
there's like action it won very many
awards it's it's to me
i think a lot of times when movies are
like this is david lynch for me david
lynch 101 when a movie is kind of vague
and up for interpretation and super
artistic we project on to it which is i
think they know that we're doing that if
a movie is very like simple or very
complicated with no narrative like david
lynch movies really it's genius genius
if you go why is it genius no one can
really explain why i don't find no
country for old men that cryptic
to me i've what's it about what's no
country from that
so tom lee jones is this guy who thinks
um
the world has gone to shit
uh when really by the end he kind of
realizes this is how life has always
been
and uh that's a big revelation and
javier bardem is this character who
it sounds like the brave little toaster
javier bardem is this character who he
he wants to kind of see himself as a
symbol of death like he goes up to
people and puts their life in their
hands and acts like he could kill them
or not the accent what what's the accent
the accent is copyrighted accent i don't
know what do you mean that's not who he
talks all the time what well that's
acting is that how he always talks cover
about them i feel like it's similar i
don't know that's how he always talks in
the book it's supposed to be someone
where you don't know his origins at all
you don't know his origins are troy
that accent is so
it was like kevin spacey in house of
cards like no one's gonna
say
anna paquin in true blood i'm just gonna
say this is crazy you don't think you
don't think about the show you know i
know what i'm saying but the accent is
not even i love it i'll say it jennifer
cool and she broke girls love that what
country is this the best part of that
show i agree you don't think
copyright i'm not scared of anyone in a
wig i'm not scared of anyone that glues
on their hair every morning
he shows up with like a vacuum cleaner
to murder people like i don't even know
whether you're murdering a bunch of
people that would easily kill themselves
if they could afford a gun like what is
this movie and why is it so dusty
why is that i don't know you're making
me want to watch it why is everything
taking so long you're going to murder
people okay god just fucking do it if
you're going to do it dude i'm a john
wick bitch like do it
you pussy and like if you spent half the
time learning to kill people that you do
to part your hair on the side javier
maybe you could like knock through some
of these corpses a little faster i find
no country for a man super intense and
super suspenseful but ultimately because
you're a guy and and very few things
scare you i think when you're a woman
you're kind of scared by everything
but it's sort of like the idea of like a
man walking in a convenience store for a
woman that's always scary whether i have
a gun or not
walk me through
now i'm gonna pretend on dates that no
country for old men is the best movie
ever made
how are you going to pretend so you want
to pretend why i feel like it's a short
a short film feels like a short it feels
like we could have done this in 15
minutes oh
feels like we could have knocked through
this faster
um
i don't know i uh
i think it's a very powerful movie about
growing older and and it what do you
know about growing older what do men i
know i'm watching no country
and the foreign every man in that movie
has a thousand crow's feet on his face
they're not worried about growing older
they're fine
well i mean they're different i i don't
think they're worried about their skin
they're worried about losing their faces
i'm literally googling what is the point
of no country for old bed yes so i wha
what does that mean explained okay
there's nine i mean i'm not just mad you
just google like what is the meaning of
life because i'm not mad because i feel
like harvard
stole my entire face and he's terrifying
totally
in general i don't think you look like
him he's terrifying in that and i love
the coen brothers and i know their
genius and blood simple i can do i can
argue why that's one of the best movies
ever made all day long but it feels a
little straightforward crime drama
follows a man who stumbles into a drug
deal gone bad tries to get away with a
case full of money okay
that was my saturday uh the film goes on
various ambiguities emerge culminating
in the ending i just think that men and
women are scared of different things or
like straight men are scared of like
this is what it takes for a straight man
to get scared is like a cattle gun and a
guy that just comes into random
convenience stores like like i think
that's what it is like when street men
do love a real movie they love a big and
a real movie and then to go oh
someone could kill me if they're
sociopathic enough so whereas every man
could kill me someone could kill me like
i think that's what it is i think that's
like that's my theory about why guys are
so afraid of robots i'm like why are you
afraid of robots like we're over here
being afraid of just regular humans and
you guys are like
future fucking about robots like oh
cause that's the only thing
you don't have any fear you're at the
top of the food chain right right so
this is what makes shit up a guy with a
bad haircut who speaks like some weird
language with a cattle gun you're like
oh fuck i'm like i mean that's not our
fault we can't i'm sorry we're not raped
i'm sorry like a lot i mean that's not
i'm not you know i think i was like i'm
not asking you to say i just mean i
think why you don't connect part of it
because i'm like there's a lot of
philosophical things going on in the
movie though like to me javier bardem is
this guy who wants to like you know the
thing what he does was recorder even
though it seems like the writers he like
flips it or something yeah it seems like
they never
knew about two-face and batman who does
the same thing but
he he flips a quarter and he makes
people flip on a quarter to to basically
execute them if they get he's trying to
show them that luck
is all that matters in life but really
what he's doing is
he's trying to he's using the fear of
death to become a symbol so like for
instance if i took a gun out put it in
front of your face you're no longer
thinking of me you're thinking of your
own death i'm just coming yeah so yeah
exactly well that's a whole other thing
but like so so he's trying to create his
own symbol of death when really is just
a human being so he's trying to show
people like the fragility of life and
how it could turn literally on a dime
but but ultimately he's just a sociopath
so at the end when he he he tries to
make the woman the woman uh his wife
flipped the coin that amazing uh
scottish accent kelly mcdonald she
refuses to she says it's not the coin
it's you she basically calls him out as
a sociopath and refuses how'd that go
well she dies but she dies heroically
which is the best you can have and yeah
she died doing what she loved she died
heroically being married
at least she was married also like the
directing of not showing her death but
having him just go outside and look at
his shoes
to see if there's blood on his shoes
that's kind of like the magic of
filmmaking that you instead of showing
things you use two cuts
to create the image in your head and
like the movie does an amazing job of
not showing things a lot but letting the
directing create the imagination you
know see that now we are like
so on the fucking same page because
i think that that is what movies really
do movies show you
that there's nothing more incredible
that's what then what's already inside
your head right like that movies can
never do justice to what you can already
imagine so so remember the movie signs
the m night shyamalan movie i'm sure
it's polarizing who cares i remember
when i first saw it
i was so scared of the enemy yeah me too
and then you realize an hour and ten
minutes in the movie you've never seen
the alien yes exactly you haven't seen
it and then actually once you see it
you're like moving fucking
that's the magic of jaws like jaws you
rarely see the shark and a lot of times
you see things just associated with the
shark and the power of the imagination
yes but but you're like oh my god the
scariest stuff is the stuff i imagine in
my head what they could actually
physically put on screen will never
compare but a big power of editing and
movies just the
the power of movies in general is this
dialectic materialism where you take one
image you take another image and you
it's the thesis and anticipation and you
synthesize in your head and create an
image right you see someone a guy
looking maybe sad then you see a shot of
a bowl of soup and you think he's hungry
right you've created the image through
two uh different ideas so no country for
all men whereas if you juxtapose it with
a coffin he's sad about that it's the
assumptions we make and how we project
which i think no country for old men
does that amazingly at times you have a
shot where you stop showing him kill
people yeah and just cut he goes up to a
a farmer with a bunch of chickens yeah
yeah yeah
can i get those chickens out of there
and then it cuts them just washing the
truck and you know he's killed the
farmer and these are like powerful like
amazing editing i didn't mean to cut
your office
stuff through that
i guess i see what you mean because but
i also am the same person whereas like i
don't like assuming the same thing
everyone assumed and i don't like this
because all i do is think about the
director
in the edible going you know what just
cut it let them figure it out like i
don't like thinking that a a person is
trying to manipulate me
with all these different way you know
it's like i have this actor pretending
to be this person i have this and i'm
trying to manipulate like i it's like
the same reason i can't stand
i'm being dramatic why i don't love
magic because i'm like i know you're
lying to me you don't love magic
well magic is just lonely men trying to
like create
there's a woman we found her okay we
found her i've hung out with magicians
trust me the magic is gone
when you hang out with them at a diner
late at night they're like i haven't
been late in seven months like can you
set yourself on fire please jesus like
like asexual haircuts but i just am very
um
i just need to know i need to be able to
dismantle the magic and then i can enjoy
it which is why which is why before i
watch a movie i this is people are gonna
lose their minds i look up the spoiler
that's insane i love you i like that
special that's insane i want to know how
the movie ends because then i don't have
to think about it i can just enjoy how
it was executed and go oh they executed
that well
because i don't want to be surprised
because then i feel like manipulating
spoilers too because then i have
something to be i'm excited i'm like
what's going to happen i think much like
me in relationships where i run away
instead of getting hurt i think you're
avoiding emotions in movies because you
don't want to be affected by them if
you've ever made a movie and watched it
without music you know that music that
movies are meaningless without music so
i think to me when i like that's a great
movie i'm always like that's actually
not that's not i mean that is true a lot
of times but if you've seen roma it
actually has no score and i've cried
interesting i didn't know that's the
entire movie
no score and that's part of it yes i
just find that a lot of times that's
what is true most of the time i'm like
what is this i i just have to know art
is manipulative it's not whether it's
manipulative or not
art is has to be manipulative you're
trying to get people through the point
yeah when when someone is saying art is
a manipulative in a pejorative way what
they're saying is
it's
it's badly manipulative in the sense
that you can tell it's manipulative yeah
so it's not that it's manipulative all
arts manipulative it's just that if you
see it being manipulative that's when it
fails you know what it is
i feel like movies to me are like porn
with guys not the guys going to porn
doing this i just go after her i just i
like to leave comments i like to let
them know smile more
um
i watch movies and go that's not real
they use like don't get your hopes up
yeah so for me as someone that grew up
on movies and television and then had a
rude awakening when she went out into
the world and was like huh
like this is you know at the time you
know because it's like people even down
to like the first time i went to a
restaurant like you sit down and you're
like where's the waitress you think
they're going to come as soon as you sit
down how's your day like nothing
matching because you treat movies like
an accent that that betrayed you you're
like i will never let i will never let
this movie movies make me feel anything
everywhere again you're not gonna get me
this time seriously three movies the way
i treat relationships you're like i
watch the spoiler so i don't have to be
moved you want to avoid when you need
somebody like just tell me now yeah
what's the problem just tell me now just
i want the shoe to drop out you're
afraid to feel something i'm afraid to
feel something and not only that i'm
afraid to get expectations that are
going to disappoint me later from movies
and i and i don't like being manipulated
and i don't like a false sense of um
like hope or or
you know as someone that i i make things
that our country world that will not
give you a false sense of hope
i don't like i i get very i think also
unsettled on a deep level that that so
many people could have such different
takes on one subjective thing that's
very unsettling to my brain because it's
like well if we can't agree on what the
best movie is we can't agree on anything
like it just it's it
people have different had such strong
opinions about one thing
disorganizes my brain it makes me feel
unsafe like no one gets along mommy and
daddy are fighting people bring so much
of their own personal emotional baggage
that's right that's right when you're
arguing someone about a movie and you
don't like a movie they like they feel
like you're trivializing their own yes
like i argue with joe about like joe has
like a lot of father issues he loves
field of dreams i don't like that movie
every guy that loves field of dreams
have fun abused by their yeah or or
their father neglected them or they suck
at sports but when i talk to you about
that movie i'm basically telling joe
your father will never be proud of you
like it's like it's like it's not gonna
happen yeah it's not i have the same
thing you can build it they won't come i
have the same thing i
the movies i cry at least
no i don't give a shit about everything
when would you cry tell us because
you're telling me just really quick do
you know how many relationships of mine
have ended because i was in love with
the guy and then he cried at rudy and i
could never fucking i don't give a shit
about rudy i don't cry on that kind of
stuff i don't care about it's about like
an underdog i mean why would that why
why you don't like crying well because
i'm just like oh you suck at football i
don't cry at inspirational it's
unattractive to watch a guy cry at a guy
pretending to play football i don't cry
like inspiration like he got it it's
like you mean the actor pretended to
suck at football i don't cry like if you
think truly
imagine how bad shawn aston sucks at
football but but actually joe is very
moved by rudy because there's a father
figure in it who's very proud of him the
music's amazing but i uh the movies i
cried out were a lot of roma but i'll i
don't know okay
i'll say a couple of movies thinking of
veda i'm like here let's play games i
love evita
i love
i could just hold school paper roll you
said the most obvious gay choices act
like it's a shocker let me just tell you
something about you you also have a
masochistic movie thing like you like to
watch movies that make you because i
think that's the other thing i think
when you've had a like uh i'm surprised
because of someone that has anxiety and
hypochondria why you would sign up to
watch movies that make you feel either
pain or loss jaws i'm crying but i keep
on watching there's a movie called
rabbit hole where nicole kidman and her
husband's baby
david lindsay bear don't make it yeah no
don't make that movie that's the movies
i want to see i want to see movies like
don't make it why do you want to see it
i won't flag i use movies to learn about
life i want to see what life is like
it's not it's a movie
but you use it it's a simulator you use
movies to like see the reality of life i
i use movies too but it's too rich
people that live in mansions pretending
they lost a child that they didn't lose
well i know it's acting
i am aware of that what about just go dm
someone who lost a child i mean like hey
can we chat for a minute do that
it's just like you don't but it's just
a whole movie real quick for me but it's
pretending
it's pretend i mean that's the one thing
it's like i
enjoy movies for what they are a bunch
of people with no problems pretending
they have problems and i'm signing up
for the the roller coaster when i get on
the the the galaxy the
ride at disneyland i don't think i'm in
the milky way i'm participating in the
delusion
i think you've lost you're disconnected
you have to buy into it still enjoy it i
do something else i do movies that are
sad i do sometimes it to me it is escape
escapism to me is being able to really
connect to other human beings in a movie
and escape your own issues so that
doesn't mean the movie has to be happy
it just is a movie that i feel like it
really is real enough that i can that i
can connect to these characters yeah so
i connect to something like timely jones
and no country for all men someone who
when you've seen movies where there's
always a sheriff by the end and every
other movie that sheriff always never
gives up in this movie he's actually
afraid and he actually gives up at the
end and leaves and that's the kind of
stuff that i connect to like it feels
like a real emotion not just the
bullshit that movies tell you but seeing
something real that excites me it makes
me feel more alone because he gave up on
the actual actor gave up on making
movies during that movie because that he
didn't understand what he was doing you
would love five vocals west he's like
what's this about
and uh but i think the magic of movies
is you don't believe in the magic movies
no you don't well here's what you're
like they're active once i've once
you've tried to make a movie and it's so
devastating and all right what movie
hurt you this is what's the thing
that celebrities do whenever they
whenever they receive like awards for
movies and they're like oh this movie
it's like no what movie yeah what movie
because
goes her whole life being temple grandin
and then claire danes wins an award for
pretending to be temple grandin and she
knows like i'm not the one that deserves
this fucking award i just pretended and
i'm fine and i don't wear vests this is
no different than it was that they just
don't go to the awards show everyone
ruined the movie every actor at some
level has the shame of knowing that
they're just pretending to be the hero
then don't take the job this is
literally no different than yelling
about men all men are liars they're all
liars you're like which guy hurt you i
can tell you why actors when they get
out there and accept no they're like um
i should probably thank the person this
is based on because i kind of just like
that's the person that lives well that's
different than being like ugh
what movie i want to know what movies
i'm not here
did you believe it and they hurt you
what come when's the last time you
laughed at a comedy show it's like that
with movies for me i i enjoy movies when
i watch a scene that is great i get
excited for the filmmaker that they got
it
that's how i can enjoy movies i i enjoy
movies when i'm like oh they fucking
pulled that off oh my god look i'm not
in how did they cut that together like
oh that editor is a genius like because
you know that movies are just made from
like you know string and shoelaces and
stuff and you're right i mean i'm not in
hollywood so i don't maybe it's like
seeing it all has but i still think it's
more than that i still think some movies
really fucked you up i want to know what
movie i agree and we're going to get to
that movies
like like hurt me yeah that gave you a
gave you like a guy gave you some here's
in faith
reality
i minored in film and was a very like
like um
pompous film major for the longest time
and like i don't like
the elephant i don't like when people
cannot admit
that some things
didn't affect them because i don't i
can't stand heard mentality i can't
stand group okay but i'm not like that i
have a genuine feeling
i try to articulate my genuine response
you are like that though this is why we
can have this conversation yeah because
i lose friendships all the time when
someone's like this movie's genius i'm
like
is it genius like are we all like yeah i
agree with that two people said it so
now we all have to say it and if i say i
don't like it i'm dumb here's what i
like though what you're saying is true
but i also just
if you like it great i hate the person
who wants to talk you out of liking it
like out in the real world it is there's
nothing worse than someone trying to
talk you out of something you like
because they think they're smarter or
they know something better i don't give
a shit that's not what movies are
foreign movie i like and if you don't
want to watch it don't come over yes yes
i do think that's silly i i i used to
argue about movie i don't really argue i
mean i i but i also think at a certain
point like i argue with joe but we're
just having fun it's like it's a
workshop yeah yeah but yeah of course
you everyone has a different general
genuine feeling and they're all
and we do have a lot of emotional
baggage tied to it like okay i'll tell
you the movies
i'll tell you a couple of the movies i
cry out and see if you can have the res
the theme of why i cry lorenzo's oil no
but i do remember that i'm being
powerful great movie three of the movies
i've cried or four i'll tell you don't
say fences
no but i was stuck in mexico we couldn't
stop crying defenses and i was like ugh
but that seemed very racist you're like
don't say roots
it's like jesus
i swear to god i saw a black guy crying
at roots what a fucking pussy if you
didn't think 12 years of slave was
hilarious get out
the movies i've cried roma which i if
you haven't seen roma yeah yeah here's
the thing it is in black and white
i appreciate the
moxie and spanish it's just like i am
why do you hate it's like to me roma i
saw it with the black and white
no no i saw the poster
and i was like okay
i'm just gonna be honest with you it's
alfonso jesus so it's obviously i
already know it's someone a brilliant
filmmaker is making it i already know
it's good i don't have to see it
you're annoyed that you know what's
going on hold on slow down i'm a person
who goes alfonso current i know it's
going to be good give me i'd vote for
him i don't even need to see it that's
how good you are you've proven yourself
i don't need to did a movie rape you why
did you but it's black and white and i'm
just this to me is like when women don't
want to know the gender of their kid
like i don't want to know it's like you
know how hard scientists work to make a
fucking machine that could show you the
gender of your child before and now you
like i don't want to know i want to be
surprised as if there's not enough
surprise the day you're giving birth
like to me this is just like
why not just use color well you got i
mean black and white can really is that
why you cry because it's in black and
white yes i haven't seen it and it makes
me feel dumb but i've seen city of god
does that fix everything
everything's gonna be good
to begin with i've seen cat city
but so okay real quick couple movie
trivia things then we're gonna get into
granular stuff arguing about movies okay
who turned down the role of han solo in
star wars who could have been han solo
in star wars oh i think i
knew this and then forgot this um
little man called al pacino
i thought it was adriana partridge but
this is a
this is a podcast no one wants to wait
around for you to think
so we would have trimmed that
people like are like is my phone bro
like they'll start fixing their car it's
not broken i just know to go quicker
jessica simpson was almost in the
notebook as the lead what but turned it
down
yeah because i think something about
boobs or something her boobs were too
big no she just didn't want to be nude
or something or have a sex scene plot
twist
jessica simpson i'm pretty sure that was
in the book i'm almost positive and
herbert pressured me to not believe in
myself are you sure she didn't just buy
a notebook
and not know what to do with it all
right what's the other other simpsons
here's why jessica simpson turned down
the role of ally in the notebook she was
offered the part that ultimately went to
rachel mcadams turns out simpson was
actually offered
offered the role of ally
she turned it down because of the
movie's now famous sex scene you're
telling me
everyone attacked me like i couldn't
read but i knew what i knew it's weird
that jessica said wow
wow that was
video and stuff no
someone different she wouldn't budge
about removing the sex scene and then
the way because during her time of being
like maybe she was like a christian all
that
was before after she was eating the
hamburger on the car naked
oh i would definitely be before i'm
pretty sure but let me ask you it's not
even nudity it's not because rachel
mcadams
they ended up cutting around it if it
was nudity i wouldn't know but that was
when she was remember she was the the
whole virginal thing and she yeah
before she just leaned into it and did
like a hazard interesting that's then
after the rally show she was more sexy
yeah yeah yeah
i mean rachel mcadam's really good
actress dirk diggler and boogie nights
was almost
leonardo dicaprio okay he was offered 20
million by landscape to trade crazed
serial killer patrick bateman an
american psycho he was also offered
americans
yes
can you imagine
um it's hard to imagine christian bale
not in that part because he's so perfect
for it is it a red flag when a guy's
favorite movie's american psycho if
their favorite movie is a movie about a
serial killer enjoys killing women and
it's like who looks in the mirror when
he rapes what yeah corpses i mean it
could be a red flag okay let's just i
love trivia like this and you probably
know all this as like a movie podcast
nothing terribly uh uh
okay so it's interesting because because
american psycho mary herron was
directing wanted christian bale she was
replaced by oliver stone who a one
whitney cummings wrote her senior honors
thesis on oliver stone jfk i wrote my
senior honors thesis on the on jfk the
movie yeah the most edits of any movie
ever at that time leonardo dicaprio and
oliver stone couldn't agree on a
creative direction
so leonardo dicaprio went and did uh a
big hit called the beach yes and herron
returned to the project and christian
bale was cast interesting i love stuff
like that
yeah it's i could see i was still making
it like natural born killers kind of but
i think it's a much better movie i mean
natural born killers to me is is if
you're going to go pound for pound
best movie best script
best directing
best acting most effective casting
natural born killers
that's funny because tarantino actually
started don't write elephants when
tarantino tarantino felt like oliver
stone did such a bad job
making a screenplay that's when he
started making his own movies yes right
oh yes but oliver stone wrote natural
born killers i'm sorry no tarantino
tarantino did but oliver stone directed
it yes and then tarantino's so upset
about how it is is there more geniuses
there are more genius casting than
ronnie dangerfield is the dad in that
movie it is pretty terrifying yeah is
there any more genius casting when
people want to say comedians can't do
drama comedians i just i'm like rodney
danger for natural killers ham
someone develops one hour photo remember
i was interning at apparently nobody's
not great at playing serial killers
great robin williams did insomnia it
just turns into a documentary yeah well
no and then and then one hour photo yeah
yeah yeah and then jim carrey and
eternal sunshine is about his mind you
still killer that i didn't see the
deleted stage no it wasn't a serial
killer but it was like very sad and
dramatic there was an interview with um
mickey rourke after the wrestler
and someone was like it was amazing how
you're able to just like cry on command
and his response was he was like oh well
that's easy for me it's not acting i'm
just always about to cry
and i was like that's it with comics
like if you're gonna
cast someone like that's true we're your
guy you know
um
who uh could not play indiana jones
harrison ford got it who almost played
indiana jones couldn't do it because he
was tied up in a tv show
chris farley uh wait no just give me a
second god damn it i'm too quick uh time
for the tv show no way you would know
this i need to start phrasing in richard
this is the worst game show ever uh tom
selleck one tom selleck almost was
indiana jones
and uh
monsters ball which went to halle berry
yes angela bassett passed oh interesting
i don't i don't that movie is much about
the great movie so intense sex scene is
real that's the rumor is on the web i
mean that that honestly i'd rather be
real than faked faking it is so much
more traumatic it's like the most
depressing i do anything to fucking
tommy candy bars
uh matthew broderick declined the iconic
role of walter white right now you're
not in breaking bad now you're not even
asking the questions can you no
not a movie i don't have time what's a
tv show i mean casting and imagine
matthew broderick like making math and
killing people
i don't know if this is a good idea or
not you know what i love here's here's
why i suck at at watching movies i love
a movie when there's continuity errors
bird cage you can see the microphone
in like you mean birdman all right no
bird cage so i went there for matt the
broadway oh oh you mean
you can see the boom mic in half the
shots oh really i love when i see the
draft half the shots in jurassic park
there's literally a part where you can
see a hand prop up of the velociraptor
it's very thick
which one
it's in the kitchen
with the starboard there was a starbucks
cup in the middle of game of thrones if
you watch ben hur uh uh which i can't
stand watching the scene because of the
horses and the in the carriages but um
he's wearing a rolex inventor
i love i remember one time i was
watching house because i was doing an
episode of houses when i first started
doing tv and i'm just calling people out
on this episode
who's the woman that was on that um
selma ward some award
she's doing a scene uh where it's just
her like on the phone and every time
they come back to her her pencils in a
different place like she put it in her
hair and then she's writing with it and
then it's in another side it's just like
continuity it's such a small thing but
it's so important yeah and such a big
deal and but i'm obsessed with i'm such
a virgo snitch i'll just watch movies
like looking for things to change i do
that yeah to avoid yourself from being
affected by it the other day i was like
and this is all because of you i
definitely blame you for it and i kept
noticing that they were frying food but
the grease wasn't on
and so they just kept taking out like
just pieces of just uncooked fish and
they just kept doing it over and over
and they cut back and i was like i would
never have noticed that i ruined movies
for you you know i just realized i
always know what's adr do you now after
watching movies with me know when it's
adr and looping
yeah
yes yeah alex is the one we went and saw
whatever it was like get out or
something like
in or i don't know something in the
theater and everything i was like i'll
go that was looping that was adr like
and it's just like stop doing that
whatever a character's talking off
off-camera that was adr she's just
acting in this part that guy doesn't
really have that house
every time someone's like closed in a
different place and i'm like that's
different everything you say about
movies is how i say about relationships
i always look for problems
i get out you know i can't like invest
in it it's like the exact your relation
to movies is my relationship to women
you're just trying to find continuity
mistakes yes exactly but weirdly enough
i don't cry in like real life but i cry
in movies all the time so i'm
emotionally invested not in
relationships but in movies we have the
exact opposite it's like but it's like
when you watch comedy you can you can
enjoy it but you're also like i know how
he did that and i get why or she did
that like i see what that means stand up
a company movies i can laugh at stand up
i guess that's what i was going to say
a little movie shrek
continuity mistake shrek in 2001 the
front door opens outwards and other
times it opened inwards yet it can't be
a two ways because whenever it closes it
slams against the frame
i don't know
i love but i love stuff like that
playing trains and automobiles when dell
comes out of the passenger side of the
dairy truck he's seen with a black eye
for no reason the next scene it's not
there it's there again when he admits to
being homeless i love stuff like that
because then the story to me is not the
story the movie it's the story
of the person
the makeup person you love it because it
keeps you from feeling emotionally
affected the same way i love seeing
problems with women so it allows me to
get out without being vulnerable
because
he's saying now you're thinking about
real life and not the movie yeah it
keeps you yeah because yeah i think for
me it's more interesting what actually
happened behind the scenes like this
like have you seen lost in la mancha
incredible documentary about terry
gilliam yeah director brazil one of the
greatest directors ever so the donkey
they were making um don quixote this is
probably a 20 year old movie i saw it at
the toronto film festival um because i
was like a movie
maniac that was my whole thing was
movies and um for longest time in los
angeles documented about terry gilliam
trying to make don quixote and it's
basically before project green light
before all these like behind the scenes
like bloopers whatever shows a
documentary crew that was coming in to
just basically do the behind the scenes
bts like interviews
behind a movie where johnny depp was
playing don quixote terry killiam's
directing terry gilliam it shows every
single thing that goes wrong during this
movie this was like the most cursed
production right he's making all these
incredible costumes for the don quixote
movie and then the costume truck catches
on fire they're shooting outside
everything goes wrong everything goes
wrong they're shooting in this
incredible desert and it never rains all
of a sudden it rains and then the way
that the clay
stains with the water it takes seven
days to dry so they can't have
continuity they can't go back to
location for seven days because that's a
they're like blow drying a desert trying
to get it to match right and then uh uh
the actor who's playing don quixote gets
testicular cancer that's right
everything's it's not johnny depp it's
that old guy they're like we can still
shoot the only thing he can't do is ride
a horse
the only thing the character has to do i
mean you just see terry gilliam being
like
i mean and then there's a storm and then
the cameras are being washed out like
it's like everything movies are ruined
for you everything that could go wrong
goes wrong and then when you make a
movie and your heart just gets broken
it's like it's like rain on your wedding
day or something when you're like i've
spent all this time trying to make this
movie and then it rains or someone
stoned or someone drops a thing in a
brick it's like the tiniest thing right
shatter the whole dream
so to me i guess i think that like to me
sometimes i just get so sensitive about
movies because it's like criticizing a
movie to me as someone that just trashed
a country for real men uh
it's like crazy
defending movies
you may have seen it's really hard for
me to be this is a good lesson for a
good few listeners to learn though don't
pull the curtain back you hate
you
so much your favorite movie is about a
movie being ruined
it's not film
yeah that's how you're like yeah yeah
fuck that movie fuck that movie
may it never get made so it'll never
hurt me and give me false expectations
of life when he just goes to sets and
ruins other people's movies
when i watch the movie
all i do is go like the audience no
matter how much you're learning and
laughing and enjoying this
so many people suffered to make this you
that's what no one enjoyed making this
if you guys enjoyed this fine but no
ever like half the people on this
production got divorced i'm clearly like
i'm making money that's the trade-off
i'm afraid of being emotionally affected
in a relationship and you're afraid of
being emotionally affected by people
that's a very good point which brings me
to how tom cruise was uh preoccupied
with another film and passed on the role
of ren mccormick and footloose
no can you imagine if tom cruise was in
footloose i can't actually i can't
imagine it's not that hard
i can imagine him at first yeah and but
loose is one of the movies where i
completely dismantle and i am
i don't know
a guy wanting to dance yeah but kevin
bacon made that movie i've had to be
fair i've never seen it
is that true i've never seen footloose
what yeah wait no full okay
you've never seen it i've never really
never seen it i've never seen footloose
oh you're not missing i've never seen
the other one either there's a two yeah
there's a patrick's swag
jesus you know nothing about love that's
why i also hate movies i'm just not
dirty dancing and literally
what this is why you don't understand
women hold on just say everyone just
everyone just calm down this is why you
don't understand women there's a lot of
reasons why i don't understand no no no
no no no if you haven't seen dirty
dancing you've seen pretty woman
i think so oh i've only seen the parts
with jason alex
i used to do try to do a joke about like
do you guys remember pretty woman jason
alexander tried to rape julia roberts
and no one liked it that's the only
scene i've seen i've seen a couple only
seen after
yeah i'm not great with like 80s it was
a debate it was actually initial horror
movie and they recut it to be a comedy
because she was so effervescent and
great and no no one in the focus groups
wanted her to die pretty women because
they liked her so much it was a horror
movie initially she was supposed to die
in the end but focus groups love julia
roberts so much how does that make it a
harvest
you mean a drama they changed it was a
yeah a drama when a woman dies i would
say that's horrific yeah
is that a horror movie why is that scary
do you think terms of a german is a hard
thing a little bit of drama i wouldn't
say
[Laughter]
okay
if y'all are still listening after all
my
hot takes
scorching
hot takes on movies
i know look look i
i believe
that
when people disagree on things that's
just called an interesting conversation
it doesn't mean you don't have to hate
me if i don't like your favorite movie
we should have what if everyone had the
same favorite things
yeah
it'd be a close it'd be so boring but
the problem is then we get a
documentary we shouldn't agree on
everything but i do feel like what all
podcasters have agreed on is that the
only cool water to have on your table
when you're podcasting
is liquid it's the only cool water it's
so annoying this isn't water this is
cool
even emily looks cool drinking this
water hold on can you wait for me please
i'm hold on this is the kind of water
it's okay liquid death you've seen it on
oh my god
okay see how cool that was
just tried to smash a liquid death
bottle okay on her forehead
and honestly it doesn't look like you
cut yourself oh no
but here's the next punk rock
that is recyclable it is recycled it is
good for the environment
and you finally drank water for once i
have to and it murdered our thirst by
the way
it did not murder uh
this thirsty bitch
but it murdered her thirst they donate
of every can sold to fighting plastic
because it's also like it's it's just
sick and they have a cool story about
their drink on the side but you have to
buy it to find now show them your koozie
the liquid death crazy the merch
i'm jealous oh my god
there's a koozie can you say it for the
listeners we've done 140 episodes i'm
still saying can you describe the thing
okay you'll take over don't worry benton
refuses to paint a picture and i hope
hydrating with liquid death will change
how would you describe it
i i know what i'm capable of
get free shipping oh my god
on all water emergent liquiddust.com
whitney that's liquiddeth.com slash
wendy or grab some at whole foods
sprouts
and 7-eleven we're about to talk about
my favorite underoos
they are called me undies this is not a
game to me
okay
i'm obsessed with me undies i had to
wear some other ratchet underwear
recently on stage and i was
a
my crevices were in a marsh
it was a nightmare
i
have rosacea of the
inner
labial fold
it was not it was a it was a miss it was
a tainted situation
it
it was uh my rock bottom frankly i would
just like to throw back to
uh a tiny clip where we tried to do a me
undies ad when jen cramer was here oh my
gosh the magician yeah when i got wasted
yeah
we
just need to share it with you that was
my rock bottom let's be honest on your
bottom rock bottom be such a good name
for a gay bar
we're playing this again
[Music]
[Applause]
called me undies what do you wear
oh my god
i thought i was going to show my
underwear
do you see any kind of uh
this is so nice
i like it i love these cards you like it
any lines on my butt i don't you've
magically made them disappear okay so we
work i don't see any honeybees me undies
is a product where you can magically
wear underwear that is comfortable
absorptive
and takes in all the the weird random um
moisture and you don't even feel it
emily
what we're gonna talk
what
why am i in trouble um
and we're back
i do believe that
when you drink the truth comes out then
my truth is that meundies
is me yeah and i put the me and me
undies and this is the time of year you
literally do put the me in there i know
it's a good it's a good slogan you guys
can have that put the me and me on these
for the company they're already thank
you so much
this is the time of year where we spend
hours days or even months trying to find
the best gifts for our favorite people
luckily me undies is back with their
ultimate gift guide so you can save time
and focus on going home for the holidays
with the coziest gifts ever
get your festive on with the new
myunders holiday collection featuring
classic plaids you know and love and
sweater inspired prints that will
quickly quickly become favorites their
undies loungewear and sleepwear are made
out of soft breathable stretchy fabrics
that are
ideal for sitting fireside with a loved
one and chatting about life over a cup
of hot cocoa
get the family photo you've always
dreamed of with matching pj sets or make
every day a spa day with plush robes and
plush slippers whatever you decide
everyone will be rolling in the new year
comfier than before available in sizes
extra small through four why are you
showing off your earrings
me undies have a little put your hair
behind you now that i bought you
earrings you need to put your hair
behind your ears at all times
the undies has a little something for
everyone on your list you have to cut
your hair by the way wait we got a bob
when he got me these beautiful earrings
for christmas and also a meundie's
prescription
first
because you have that that that coochie
frog
there's a prescription
i knew this was gonna be a thing i knew
it and i no you're the only one upset
about it don't buy gifts for people i
like it just only buy me undies everyone
in the room likes their gift but whitney
she hates the gifts she bought us and is
projecting and i think that that's right
i think i nailed it but me on youtube
i love mine great offer for my listeners
for any first-time purchasers you get 15
off and
free shipping right to your door your
days of fighting for your life in the
mall parking lot are over there oh man
that's really funny
get 15 off of your first order free
shipping and 100
satisfaction guarantee and i hate
everything go to meundies.com whitney
that's
slash meundies.com
don't slash man please don't splash me
but it's dot slash whitney the the
backslash the now not the verb
now back to my friend
i know that but i second guess myself
okay so dirty dancing here's the thing
about movies like that dirty dancing and
photos like i don't know if watching it
now would have the same cause those
movies were so pivotal to me like what
were the most pivotal movies where
you're like
i learned something about myself or i
i expanded as a person like do you have
any of those pivotal movies dirty
dancing and footloose i think you would
love footloose like a town with all
these rules
i do think i enjoy that i'm learning a
lot about me and if i had a chance to
have any fun you said what if nobody
danced and they used coasters
wouldn't that be a treat i don't know i
i feel like they're so
no one dances at prom i like this place
i feel like i don't know there's a lot
of 80s movies i just haven't seen that's
the decade i don't haven't seen as much
of it i feel like anytime someone tells
me to watch this 80s movies they're like
it's amazing and then i watch it and i'm
like yeah it's like they don't hold up
and i don't know like i think that dirty
dancing when you when i first watched i
mean adam ghost
excellent actually i just saw that
recently excellent but here's the thing
i don't know like i i go back and over
the paint up like i've watched a lot of
movies that i hadn't seen him on i
watched charlie and chocolate factory
emily knows i watched a lot of shirley
temple movies i watched all these movies
i was like jesus these do not hold up
charlie chocolate the old one dude it
looks like a like a fifth grade science
project well the special fabric it's
insane the special effects don't hold up
but the there's the humor special effect
you mean the duct tape you mean the
science of the poster
i mean it's what should be the diorama
that eventually handicapped kid brought
to science fair you mean the make-a-wish
project i mean well i mean yes but like
you're like my brother my brother's like
i could never watch a movie from the 70s
but emotionally it holds up it's funny
gene wilde is really funny i think as an
adult i go oh there was all this
commentary here that i was too young to
understand before it's about kid like
parents coddling their kids and not
being the parents and allowing their
kids you know what kind of psycho goes
into watching a movie from the 70s like
this better be the same quality as today
it accents the viewing experience like
if you go back and watch a clockwork
orange now it's even creepier and
weirder because because of the but the
quantum quote see the children's movies
you're like watching with the rivas oh
that doesn't hold up you can tell that
horse is painted
no you're just like why is this 16 year
old hanging out with all these old guys
all the time like it's weird i'm like
and why is she taking care of all their
emotional feelings like it's more like
as an adult you step back and you're
like oh judy garland was 15. all these
other actors were 76 and like and why
it's only one pair of nice shoes in the
whole city and i know back then that the
makeup that the witch is wearing is
super toxic and flammable and i know the
story behind the movie i know she got
like
there are a lot of things that could
make you sad about wizard and i'm like
clown long well yeah what well you've
got clown lungs so what about the fact
that they're drugging julian garland
with speed the whole time to keep her
well that's hollywood baby
yeah
what do you mean they gave her like
adderall
it wasn't called adderall at the time
but i believe it was the benzos or
whatever they call back that well that's
a downer isn't it isn't it
like a like a xanax or uh no i think
that's nice i learned this in family
therapy no i think there was a different
term for it but they gave her speed a
lot yeah but also i mean you know it's
also i mean that movie like her life is
very tragic but i read a whole article i
don't know that how did she die judy
garland i don't know i swear oh really i
thought you're being successful i'm not
i'm not sure
it was alcohol or drugs
but i think it was drugs
um she had a really hard yeah um
but also you know what i read this is
how little women mattered on the set
back then she was constantly apparently
i saw a headline it was a true story it
said her her ex-husband said she was
molested
on the set by by munchkins
it was a weird headline because they
were referring to the fictitional i
didn't laugh at that and i think i
deserve a trophy but it's it was really
funny because you said munchkins the
headline really did say much kids which
is hilarious that wasn't fair you said
munchkin it's a ridiculous it's like i
mean you could have said like keebler
elves or something it was a ridiculous
headline because they were using those
like it was it's like saying they were
munchkins like willy wonka got raped by
oompa loompas it's like an insensitive
headline but apparently she did get
molested by the little people on the set
she was below the little people
themselves
one of the munchkins i don't know if
that's true though that might be that
could be a lie that that might be
apocryphal
i mean you might you might have just
like i just heard it no i've heard that
a mousetrap okay so okay so judy garland
being molested by munchkins i'm going to
sit this one out
um because i have a hot take which is if
just run away i'm sorry
i'm just jumping i'm sorry am i an
asshole just go to uh i'm just just
fight a stepladder
i'm just i'm sorry but you would have so
many of them you would have to
accommodate them to be molested by them
you would have to do a deep squat i mean
i just i'm sorry am i'm an asshole maybe
maybe they were emotionally they were
like they'd be like can you pick me up
just for fun and then she picked them up
and then they grabbed how do you get
molested by a munchkin ha i'm just i'm
i'm not going to be a dead skin is not
the politically correct term it's little
so they gang raped her you mean the
munchkins gang munchkins since part of
me i think they'd like they'd probably
just jump up and like
pat her ass and then walk away they
grabbed her they don't know how funny
they are they took her into a tree truck
well you know a couple of them had
lollipops so that made them taller yeah
they maybe yeah
sweetly i'm just
i just need someone to walk me through
it
it's hard to victim blame because it's
hard to know who the victim is
is it justice if we call the midgets in
this story
are we all good if we say these midgets
molested her no you should call them by
the proper term munchkins um
they're not friends of dorothy so here's
what i'll say as a as someone that is
trying to feel about the right side of
history i think that it is not what is
the opposite of feminist whatever i feel
like true though this is true i feel
like i'd be on the wrong side of history
if i
defended her
that's how little women mattered on film
sets back then the lead of the movie
not
she really felt like such a small little
person during this according to a 2005
memoir of the
by the third of garland's five husbands
what i don't know well that's why you're
i don't know about the third jesus
sydney luff said the actress was
molested by the actors playing the film
swear to god the headlines said munchies
the headlines said they thought they
could get away with anything because
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
they thought they could get away with
anything because they were so small
apparently they were and they were right
what they lack in body size they gain in
intelligence you know how upsetting it
is though like she's the lead she goes
to the director like can you stop these
little people from molesting me and
they're like look
in terms of power dynamics you are way
below what did they do
just give me one second give me a second
hold on hold on hold on hold on
uh judy garland was 16 when she started
the 1939 movie the wizard of oz she
claimed she was molested by the actors
who played the munchkins and one horse
from emerald city i heard it
sorry
from the actress's late husband sid luft
he re-released in a re-released book
anyone that's re-releasing their book i
don't trust this person he's like did
you guys not get it the first time i
feel like no one saw it i'm gonna
re-release if you're re-releasing
something you're very desperate this is
hearsay also she there's no record of
her saying it yeah just hold on my life
with judy god he reportedly writes
what do you mean he reportedly writes
did the journalists not read it
they don't know who wrote it really he
allegedly wrote that he alleged that she
allegedly made his life miserable and
set by putting their hands under her
dress yes the men were 40 or more years
old
the lollipop killed
they thought they could get away with
anything because they were so small
she's a victim of male predators no
matter how cute they appeared well
that's a little insulting
to say about them they're predators no
matter how adorable and you can insult
predators
yeah but you can't install little people
you can't call little people cute only
if they're predators
but then they're cute predators exactly
which is why it's garland previously
claimed the munchkins were quote drunks
who partied all night
but maybe because you guys called the
munchkins and made them carry lollipops
i'm pretty sure at the end of the
credits they literally say and thanks to
all the munchkins like they don't even
call them by the real i would like by
the way let him have it
let him have it
um hold on are we on in this story it's
a great idea i mean look i want to go
that far but it is tough you are dealing
with two groups that are very much more
like we want you to
run around and carry lollipops and be
like silly little munchkins well that's
not judy's fault but judy's like a 16
year old girl on speed you know i'm just
saying if they're drunks i get why
they're drunk number one they're
lightweights yeah number two they just
smell they just smell beer they get
wasted hold on this number one they're
lightweights number two they're
lightweight they're this gets more
degrading garland herself claimed the
munchkins were drunks who parted all
night and the police rounded them up in
butterfly nets that can't be real this
feels like a fair fight it feels like a
fair fight you know how you see in the
old movies the the crate
they have the butterfly nets that's the
only people that could work with the
butterfly nets okay uh the the one of
the munchkins his last name is marin uh
what do you mean rounding them out like
they're just running off like stop stop
yeah they just throw nuts on you put
them back together they had a tree trunk
to go back yeah
i still hired like hedgehogs one of the
munchkins responded to the allegations
after being offended saying that
toto was paid more than the munchkins
and there's no way they could get drunk
on amigas
on a meager salary of 50 a week
dude honestly that's hilarious their
response is toto got paid more which is
basically saying we did it but oh no we
were little but we were a little enough
in the basket well i mean
mark
pavinelli president of the little people
of america
commented quote i contacted a close
friend of jerry marin the one that said
that
don't name a little person jerry
unfortunately due to jerry's health he
hasn't been in a condition to give an
interview okay so he's not chiming in
he's refuted these accusations of
molesting judy garland and i'm sure he'd
do the same now if he were able to as
unable to get in a chair and email back
i thought he could give a response how
did he say that he couldn't reach the
computer he said i can't give response
but here's what he said
in response to the actors and judy
garland's judy garland called them quote
little drunks
not not funny it's not not funny
these allegations were more serious the
sexual molestation of a minor in the
workplace so i guess between a 15 year
old and a munchkin who's the miner
that's the big fight here
well definitely the 15 year old yeah
so woke up uh for what it's worth marin
seemed to respect garland previously
saying she was quote wonderful to work
with we expected her to be a snobby
movie star she was more excited meeting
us than we were meeting her
i never met any little people he said i
was the only small person in my family
making the film was the greatest fun i
ever had in my life because i got to be
exposed to other little people and see
they could be successful great win
uh also we weren't trying to grab her
pussy we're trying to slap her and
that's as far as we could
we were just trying to get up to see the
view
what's so sad is is uh
like it's all these different
marginalized groups together all
screwing each other and then the sad
thing is not only did toto get paid more
but they knew that which means on set
the director was like hey toto
you're getting paid way more than these
fucking little people like they let them
know so judy garland also was her like
she also was i think couldn't stop
giggling in a take i think this is known
and the director smacked her in the face
in order to
like get her to be whatever then she
slapped a cowardly line it's a cycle of
violence
if she wanted to slap one of the
munchkins she'd throw out her back so
she had to
um we are officially rooting wizard of
oz dude this is funny though this is my
god here's the thing this is i'm gonna
get so much stronger this
thing really puts woke people in a tough
position because they can't be like
those little people were monsters i
guess they can't they were little drunks
they got smashed every night
they picked them up in butterfly nuts i
just don't i don't know i'm on the
munchkin side is that bad am i a bad
person
well they would probably not be on your
side because you called them munchkins
that's
you know what i mean monsters don't make
me
this is so i feel so bad for them the
politically correct people are calling
the monsters
but but you know i mean i'm defending
them don't come at me for saying the
wrong word quill is defending you do you
remember okay i'm not gonna i'm now i'm
going on a tangent and if you know
anything about me you know that i could
spend another five hours just talking
about this and we have to move on but
this is why i can't enjoy movies
because i get too deep in wormholes
about the allegations behind the scenes
but did you know that marley wingrawl
looked in at an early script a pretty
woman turned it down molly ringwald
turned it down paul giamatti turned down
playing michael scott in the office
oh really can't see it can't imagine it
i can imagine it
me too me too
you know what ganna mansion you know my
mind i lied i'm a liar you're right i'm
exaggerating like they're all like these
crazy things that i'm like what am i
doing those actors seem pretty similar
yeah
no he could totally do it
turn down portraying dr ryan stone in
gravity if you said giamatti turned down
like iron man or like uh superman i feel
like i can't see that jack nicholson
declines starring as michael corleone
in the godfather that feels like
something a straight guy would be upset
about upset or just like whoa
i mean that's that's a little more
that's why is the godfather such a big
deal to men
i think it's a big deal to some women
too not all women but uh sophia coppola
yeah i mean i think uh but like what is
it about a man who is both god and
father of all things but but what is it
like why like because i think that in
order to be in a relationship
you have to understand
why another movie is important to
someone
and and respect it and not shit on it i
mean that's true but watch it let's just
cut to the chase here well you want to
date a straight man and you're a
straight woman you have to
like fight club or at least understand
why guys like it if you are a man that
wants to date a woman in the light you
have to understand the princess bride
you have to understand dirty dancing i
love to like i love
you don't have to like it but you have
to understand why it's important to us
easy
women princess brides these are these
are you're making it a gender thing
a lot of people i love princess bride a
lot of men love princess pride and i
hate fight club so it's not like this is
progressive this is and i feel like
you're bunching fight club in with like
godfather i mean i know a lot of guys
but godfather's like an amazing film
classic that's not like yeah yeah that's
like saying like you know i just i
wonder
like movies are so i just wonder if
sometimes we use movies
to like
feel like um
i think sometimes we use movies not as a
drug not as a it's just like god fuck it
to have an identity yeah a hundred
percent that's what it is that's the
only thing we use them for
i think there's just douchey people like
everything but if a movie is popular
there's gonna be idiots who like it just
like there's you know but i do think
that a lot of times like our favorite
movie we there's so much on it and then
it's like if i just like the godfather
i'm smart if i just like these movies
i'm interesting if i just like this
movie i'm feminine if i just like you
know what i mean like movies carry so
much weight in terms of like if someone
on their dating profile says my favorite
movie is this i've already made i
already know everything i know about you
which isn't true
but what do you know about me i think it
is loving i love sideways big lebowski
no country for old men roma
what do you know about me from that
you're an alcoholic who sucks at bowling
who wants to go to italy and you really
like everyone sucks at bullying no what
i hear from that no i when i hear from
that is like
if you say that i'm going oh this is a
really well-rounded person who's like
super nuanced and isn't afraid of
feeling feelings and isn't afraid of um
the complications of like aging but also
wants to laugh and like that was such an
interesting um diversity of movies that
you just picked if you were like i love
fast and furious john wake and the
godfather i'm like you cheat well you're
wrong i always say those to get laid
i'll tell you yeah yeah i mean for me
it's not like a gender i mean i haven't
seen footloose i i i guess i don't
always love rom-coms yeah but you know
that's not to say i don't love movies
starring women and i you know i love
roma i love the florida project which is
but i also think though
unfortunately this is important because
i think that the main thing that that
you know is worth digging into here is
that i think for the most part men
you know what not men women too i wasn't
encouraged to have any feelings i was
encouraged to you know cry when i was
sad i was like you know i think that
that
a lot of times movies are so important
for men because i feel like it's almost
the first time you're allowed to see men
expressing emotion or
feel emotion without it being a weakness
and without they're only certain times
they're allowed to cry where big brother
or your big brother won't beat the shit
out of you because you're crying because
you hurt your knee but then i can cry
during field of dreams or rudy it's
catharsis you know it's whatever but you
know i just i just get a little bit
bumped when a conversation is just about
movies and i'm like i don't want to be
judged by my intelligence my emotional
intelligence my academic intelligence by
what movies i do and don't like and it
gets it's almost like what annoys me
about people that are like team people
like i'm cowboys versus the dolphins
versus like
like i don't like being reduced to my
favorite movie i don't like being
reduced to my team i don't like being
reduced to where i'm from i don't like i
just right for some reason mo people use
it as a way to just go oh you're this
person you love clueless you're this
person uh
yeah i mean
well i feel like you gotta do that why
don't you say you could tell people by
the movies
i think people also want that sometimes
i think yeah maybe they're a way for
people to be like yeah i don't know how
to express this thing that i am or like
or want yeah and so this is the easiest
way to do it
yes that's true that that and i think
that for me i'm scared by how much a
movie a movie that you like says about
you or what your opinion about a movie
says about you and i think it's someone
that is like i'm so afraid to express my
opinion most of the time as you can tell
i'm very shy but it just feels like
like i have such hot takes on things i
feel like i've like had friendships blow
up and relationships grow because we
can't
it's like i can like a movie
and you don't why can't we like
different movies and it not be a deal
breaker that's been a deal breaker
me
me challenging no country for old men
has really is why i don't have kids well
we're still what
because if it goes beyond the movie
it's like now you're saying it's like
you don't understand me yeah everybody
some other issues in this movie it's
connected to something important about
me and now you're saying it's dumb
therefore you think you didn't make it
you just went and watched it why are we
interested in everything that's like you
don't make the clothes you wear would
you pick them out for a reason yeah you
didn't make the music listen too but
yeah for a reason i think people get mad
at movie arguments because they're
insecure and they don't know how to
defend their own opinion and then they
get angry and they can't defend it and
then they get mad i'm not defending it
wait wait wait wait wait secure so you
can shoot no country this
this is powerful because i think a lot
of people have trouble articulating
their emotions myself included and
showing emotions but sometimes a movie
will do it for them that's what artists
do well they are able to like use
symbolism and allegory to construe
something that's really hard to
articulate and then
you're making you're i'm learning a lot
right now because i'm learning that if
someone's like this is my favorite movie
instead of going like i don't get that
movie it's like oh you're trying to show
me more about yourself yes and i just
need to understand that movie to
understand because that movie is is
construing something that you maybe
can't convey on your own i don't even
understand the movie just understand and
then what is it about the moon that they
relate and then
and then it puts them in another bind
which is now they have to defend this
movie that
now they have to articulate why they
like this movie that helped them
articulate their feelings to begin with
so you put them in a double bind of a
double i'm not being able to articulate
myself and if i say i don't like the art
exists it's because if everyone can make
the thing that they could say or do they
wouldn't be artistic not
we could all just articulate and be the
thing we wanted to be and there would be
no need and they ain't making any art
anger comes from not being able to
articulate if you can have words that
articulate the anger isn't going now i'm
learning which i used to be able to i
used to go like we should be able to
disagree on movie you like this movie i
like this movie i should reserve like to
not like this and you know as you know
like i should be able to say my opinion
without feeling like you know i'm going
to be judged or like you're not going to
respect my opinion or like i have big
you know big ideas and big thoughts and
i we should be able to have different
pay but what i'm now realizing is that
when people say this is a movie that
means like when i say i don't like that
movie i'm saying i don't like you
they're they're or i don't i don't you
know like
i'm now realizing why it's not because
for me movies are so um for the most
part objective and um not meaningless
but i don't use them as a way to say
this is this is me filling in a blank i
can't fill in myself this is me sharing
myself with you i can't necessarily say
i love you and i'm vulnerable or
whatever but this is my favorite movie
together
we're communicating to you i jim just
realizing in this moment
that
i've said like i don't like that movie i
don't get that movie or i feel like
you've just ever made it if you do that
with with flowers with your horse you
use other things to articulate how you
feel they're just not movies all the
time sometimes you might be like these
coasters and we're like they're coasters
but to you they mean something really
important but and beyond like and not be
on like using them like the actual
design or whatever it means like do you
are you were you are you listening or
not but all these questions
on the flip side of like you can be
reduced down to something you can't be
like i love these seven wrong cons and
someone's like oh so you're just a dumb
like which isn't necessarily the truth
but i think in terms of but i think what
i'm learning is that movies don't have
to be a sport instead of like i like
this movie and you like this movie and
let's fight about why it's like oh you
love that movie you're trying to let me
in
yes
more on who you are and instead it's not
up for debate whether i like it or not
you're trying to offer me some form of
vulnerability it's like all art it's a
conversation you just open yourself up
to me and it's not about whether it's
technically good or not
it's like you're sharing something with
me it can't be that i think i think
another thing that can create anger in
that situation is when certain people
like a certain movie they usually
sympathize with the character in it so
when someone says they don't like that
movie it's almost like they're saying i
don't sympathize with you like i see
myself interested in paul giamatti and
sideways so much so when it's in the
office so when someone says
uh i don't like sideways i just didn't
like those characters like you're saying
you don't like me yeah or you don't have
compassion for the kind of situations i
deal with so that that gets dicing or
you've never seen life through my lands
or how i right that's so
interesting because i feel like now and
you don't care enough to go learn or
watch it you also think you don't need
to see like that or i had my experience
that movie and i didn't feel that much
and i'm dismissing your experience but
i'm dismissing that there could have
been something in there that meant
something to you even if it didn't
resonate with me there's something i
like i'm now learning how personal
movies are to people because i guess to
me it's like i just go for the technical
did they stick the landing this work did
this casting work i like i watched
movies and tv going they wanted this
person they didn't get this person uh
they lost their life it keeps on ruining
the illusion of the movie that's why
you're so into like oh there could have
been this other actor it just reminds
you that it's not real which brings me
to my question what are the movies that
hurt raped me well yeah which ones are
they i mean i guess it's not your fault
it's not your fault
you better not say goodwill
you better not fucking take it away
raping was my favorite what are the
movie yeah that that made you a cynic i
think for me as soon i grew up without
um a lot of like you know i did i i
watched tv a lot i watched movies i
watched tv and i escaped into which i
think a lot of people did this is not a
unique experience and then i grew up and
i kept like i remember singing a
musician named amy grant
um
baby like
you know and i pictured a man singing me
that and i was like oh when you go on a
date that's what guys sing to you
like these lyrics like like when i go to
an airport a guy's going to show up with
flour like i didn't understand
whatever reason that my psyche needed to
check out and believe that fantasies had
to be real whatever
my psyche needed in order to delude
itself to stay hopeful or positive it
was all like
crocodile dunny i mean it was i mean as
a teenager as even in my 20s this is
embarrassing to say but anytime i went
to like a subway station i was like
waiting for the guy was dating to like
show up that's not embarrassing that's
people right now any age you are you are
living whether you know it or not you're
living some part of a movie i all the
time think in my head i'm like i don't
think i would have done anything in my
life if i wasn't always being like well
i wanna i wanna live this way i wanna
live like that i wanna do this i'm
constantly
like uh mirroring my life to some some
like even little things like the soap
that i buy i'm like this reminds me of
the soap that was sitting in the seal on
the
i think most people do i think most
people are living with some kind of
reflection of
songs or movies or tv shows and i think
that there's also a resilience that i
maybe wouldn't have had otherwise where
it's like oh in the third act they
always overcome like like problems are
always solved in movies it's always
sorted out at least the movies you know
it's like the the guy always gets the
girl or you know we're crocodile d they
always catch the flight and they get you
know so i think to me a part of my
resilience was like no matter how badly
it's going
the hero's gonna win in the end like
that's just how it goes like so i think
for me i never
you know um you know uh acquiesced to my
circumstances or got hopeless because i
was like oh my god this is exactly what
would happen at the end of act two
the hero would rise so i i always was
like oh i'm just at the end of act two
they're still in act three that's one of
those things where like life in the
tapes aren't takes life because in life
that's what happens you're never going
to be at your lowest point forever right
right really movies are just imitating
life in that way that's right right
exactly that's why it feels believable
that's why when you watch a movie you're
like oh my god that feels i see they
went through a struggle and that feels
like this even though you may not have
been you know a drug addict dying in the
street singing but yeah you know it
feels like something very similar to you
just maybe not being able to buy your
subway sandwich you know and to me like
movies i think i relied on them so like
almost like a drug
as a as a kid and as a an escape that by
the time i became an adult i was like
i think i had a little bit of a
bittersweet taste in my mouth because i
was just like
all you do is i can make me think things
going are going better than they are and
all you do is give me this like
delusional sense of
how life is and i can't fuck with you
anymore like i need to and then i got
super into documentaries yeah i want to
get back at movies
it was that was my rebound yeah my
revenge was i watched a bunch of movies
that are that and i started trying to
make a documentary i was making a
documentary about female breakdancers in
uh brooklyn when i was in college and
uh it was really how did i take all the
magic of movies and ruin it and like
literally ruin it and then my camera got
stolen and if you have it
i'm not mad at you and you know that
even that disappointed if anyone makes a
shitty documentary about female brave
dancers in the early arts
godspeed i can't wait to see it um but
then i got really into documentaries
about like what's real life like and
what's what's struggle like and i don't
want to look away and i don't want to
keep pretending that prince charming is
going to save the day i don't want to
protect like pretend like everything's
just going to magically but it's like
it's like over-correcting you're going
to extremely other way yes and then now
with movies i i know myself and i know
my ability to get swept away into
romantic uh delusion and and i i just
have to sort of like watch myself i have
to go like okay that was a movie and
that was that was an extra and that was
a stunt double and that was a different
because i know myself and i know that i
will get swept up in this and then i
will get my heart shattered when real
life happens
it's the same thing the thing is the
thing we don't have a lot of feelings
for is the things we have the most
feelings for that we trust only the
difference is that your relationships
don't last the length of a movie
they much shorter yeah
much shorter yeah but also sometimes
it's easier right it's easiest to face
real life problems through a lens of
fantasy and then you can get a clear
answer for real life looking through
something and also the subway thing is a
great point about how like
something small in your life you can
connect to something bigger the movie if
you want to know why people love the
godfather it's because
there are a lot of big tragic things
that happen that allow people to relate
when he kills his brother fredo in the
second one a lot of people connect that
spoiler alert
statue of limitations wow and people
connect to that like a sibling they
haven't talked to in a while yeah or you
know they through that
the godfather's shakespearean thing
where it's like through these big acts
you see a universal thing that you can
connect to smaller things in your own
life totally totally and there's some
kind of catharsis or feeling or escape
but i think for me the any escape you
know movies was maybe and tv was like my
first drug you know before food before
you know any of the relationships people
actual drug all right and i think that i
know myself and i know i can leave a
movie so high
on i'm that person or
that's possible or the wedding and the
thing and the dress and the like and
then he'll cheat and but he'll meet you
at the airport and everything will be
fine like i
want life to be that fun and easy and
sexy and romantic and facile that
watching movies like
it does undo a lot of progress in terms
of that's not how life works that's not
life on life's terms like but that's not
there's only a certain type of like the
movie guys higher 20s every time i got
off a plane i was like
i love that that's waiting for a guy so
much better though then get off the
plane and be like i got my fucking
luggage now yeah but that's but then you
don't get disappointed because you just
go your luggage that's it instead of
your
baggage but now you can be like even if
a guy really did like me because of 9 11
it's not going to happen anyway so it's
like it also depends on what you what
you're like i guess if you're if you
only are like um internalizing the love
scenes yeah yeah disappointing yeah i
think you know if you internalize like
i don't know edward scissorhands or
something then you go through laughing
like i'm never a weirdo interesting yeah
yeah yeah if you internalize yeah meryl
streep never works proud of your life
you're gonna be the fucking boss
or like should be like sideways is a
movie about not getting things you want
like you know at the end he accepts that
like he probably won't ever be famous
but this woman really likes his novel
and he sees the values connected with
one person he gives up on the the giant
dream of mattering in the universe he
and he realize the importance of
connecting with one person so that's
acceptance but the actor got to accept
an oscar but sometimes i don't think but
i refuse this that's a good lesson in a
movie sometimes one person is a prize
yeah
but then yeah then then maybe just like
the the award shows ruining it because
like oh you were pretending that whole
time like that was never really your
reality which is why i think document a
healthy balance of documentaries
and fiction movies i think are the key
because i can't do too much fiction or
else i
i it's susceptible
and that is enough balance that you can
you can dive into a movie or a book or
whatever your vibe or your thing is my
life has been pretty cushy so i love
really dark movies i think for me that's
maybe a little escaping interesting
interesting interesting or a little bit
like you're going through a haunted
house yeah and i never got to do all the
things i wanted to do so i like
everything to be a camp i like every
movie to just be just this much out of
reality yeah right right i just i'm an
aberration maybe because i will leave
like um
spider-man being like
okay
i need dental floss and i'll be like to
my boyfriend just crawl up this out of
the building like that's how yeah i ta
my brain runs my hair black and white
when gorilla came out do you remember i
do i that's that's the world i'm living
in here yep i got home and put on robes
with first leaves and i'm like i'm here
but i'm too i i just yeah i know i would
have got a hundred i would have rescued
a hundred dollars and i would have made
them into a coke i watched corella 27
times the one with emma stone recently i
know it's not fair because we're all
relating but that's a little insane
not only that but i also invited
everyone to go watch it with me all my
friends and then watched it three times
before i went to go with them wait wait
are you watching the ball in movie
theaters or no oh wait this is recent
this is the one with emma stone yeah i
mean i watch the other ones a lot too
just because i just know i knew i would
like it i knew i liked that character i
knew like that personality boy were you
right you watched it twice several times
i knew and i said i'm not going to
deprive myself of this or be
embarrassing people like i don't want to
see that nothing then don't come but i
love that but you see but but that that
is like the healthy i think even though
it sounds like addiction about that
that's so bad but that to me is like
but yeah
yeah i don't know well we'll probably
we'll unpack that later i know i like it
why would i want to do something
i
here's what i'll say if you like one
thing and you watch it fucking 50 times
that is someone that knows themselves i
respect that instead of going i love
corolla but now i'm going to go watch
this movie about a couple whose baby
died just to punish myself and to like
feel cool at parties and to be able to
like have about mr rabbit that's the
thing because i don't like obligatory oh
obligatory
obligatory movies that if you haven't
seen it you're dumb or not people cheat
movies now as if it's the
odyssey oh you haven't seen so and so
that's not a book that you read you're
not you didn't go to a like a like you
don't have a phd because you saw a movie
epic said you're not better than this
culture watching a movie from start to
finish it is like the new reading a book
it is pretty impressive people come at
me like oh you haven't seen so it's like
and if you haven't seen a movie that's
bad
and everyone's using it as a camera oh
you haven't seen cats like no i'm sorry
i haven't hate fucked a movie and like
watched a movie that everyone doesn't
like and like make fun of everyone who
thought they were doing a good job and
like mocked nothing's better than
someone being like oh you haven't seen
cats it's horrible and you'd be like i
know and i still like it what i don't
like movies i think it's not like that
it's not shitting on cats when i don't
like movies and this goes back to the
personal thing i think it's when i see
just like the same way if you shit on
someone
for liking something it makes it feel
like you don't like them
when i see people
connecting to goodwill hunting or
something that i find really
manipulative and stupid it makes me feel
alienated i think on some level because
i'm like how do you how do you like such
bullshit and i don't so it goes both
ways
i get mad where the movie is so loved
but when i feelings
but here's what i will say i will say if
you're on a date with someone and you're
like oh good will hunting's manipulative
and tradual and if you like goodwill
hunting
this isn't a bag
if you like it what life is if you like
goodwill hunting i'll be able to win you
over very easily that's true
yeah i mean that's the other thing when
i date it's all lies i don't know like
my actual opinions
when someone likes a movie that i don't
like instead of going uh
you don't live in this like constant
malaise of over criticizing everything
that's like perfectly fine and like the
filmmaker wasn't trying to appease you
also like this person can enjoy the
simple things in life why don't i just
value that you like goodwill hunting
i should be around you
you just a movie plays you like it and
then you move on you don't spend your
entire life going what is everyone like
that like there's something kind of
uh admirable about someone that can just
enjoy that also you can hate me that's
totally fine yeah
i mean you gotta have a balance you just
have to know yeah you have to know where
to hate it like monster truck rallies i
don't understand that shit what are we
doing out there yeah yeah but i don't
need to go to one and be like you're you
idiots up in here yeah yeah yeah if but
it's also it's like i think to me you're
making me learn like if we don't like
the same thing
it doesn't mean i'm right i'm not right
you right
if you are able to enjoy a movie that
sole purpose was to be enjoyed you knew
the assignments i don't need you like
everything i like in fact don't but i
like what
yeah that's correct but more than
anything else movies music podcasts
comedy books if you books what is a book
if you if your favorite movies ever says
your hands and i'm like oh the
relationship will never work we put so
much on we have to like the same movies
if if your favorite movie is this
because i will say with god there's a
lot of red flag stuff with me and guys
if a guy's favorite movie is fight club
at american psycho i'm like oh more than
needing to agree on it i think what i
need from other people is i just need
you to understand why i like it and
that's all i really need that's it i
don't need anything else i don't need
you to ever watch this i just need you
to understand why it's meaningful to me
and we can move on right i mean but it's
also depending on who you like i don't
argue like if i'm talking to people like
on a date i don't argue about movies if
they say they love goodwill hunting i'm
not like goodwill hunting sucks you're
an idiot i just say yeah it's pretty
good i don't like arguing yeah so you
just lie yeah i lie yeah i only talk
about movies on my podcast or for
talkies
i just manipulate my notes yeah to be
fair nobody else probably thinks about
this about anything else but i think
this is a room of people who are
everything matters to me down to like i
mean yeah the the the this phone case
i'm a maximus everything in my life
there's nothing i need all and this
matters that you have to understand why
yeah and i think most people are just
like i just like we just watched some
movies it's just amazing
yeah but i do think it's it's a
testament to how hard it is sometimes to
communicate and show yourself to people
that sometimes in the beginning of a
relationship
you show yourself by saying what your
favorite movie is
and and
i'm just i still don't know the answer
and i know we have to get out of here
but i still don't know if someone says
my favorite movie is this if i'm
supposed to
internalize that as a part of their
personality if i'm so am i supposed to
take it seriously or not that's why i
still don't know the answer okay that's
why so if someone says hey my favorite
movie because my favorite
i believe
the best crafted movie
it's a very hot take is irreversible by
gaspar noe this is a movie that was told
in reverse
uh in three takes with monica bellucci
and vince absolutely
vincent castle i almost said cavisel but
you didn't have to explain why it's your
favorite movie now you've already told
us i know but i'm just saying you watch
a rape for five minutes if i'm just
meeting a new person and i say that
they're gonna be like this bitch is dark
and cryptic and trying to shock me and
try to scare me and maybe keywords i got
were crafted three takes and in reverse
so now i know that you don't really care
about the movie you care about how it's
made it's the movie that
i still think about 20 years after
watching i just love how you're like
fight club that's a red flag and then
your favorite movie
to me it's the most in terms of pound
for pound
sorry to say that about a rate movie
pound for pound in terms of
like like
bravery yeah and skill
that movie is like wasn't done in post
music didn't fix it
voiceover didn't fix it it was like oh
you guys shot it you got it like editing
i wasn't manipulated i wasn't lied to
you made me it changed the way i think
it changed that movie changed the way i
think not that that is what every movie
i think that was very clear so now i
know going into conversation or when
that you are looking for tech different
things that i'm looking for and stuff
you're looking for technical things
you're looking for
i love that movie going i feel like i
owe you more money
i gave you eight dollars no you you
probably paid them more i was like
like that was
so
brave and such a feat
that i am like michael bay movies people
baby movies dude you try to make a movie
like what he they have everything people
want like it or don't like it
it took so much i'm just like this took
a lot of time to mate they have actually
that impresses me i get upset when
things are mind-numbing i i get upset
when things don't have you ever edited a
movie for 12 months that's my numbing
i'm like if you think your brain is numb
imagine michael bay so but you can't
play that's like i hate that house have
you tried to build a house you can't
play that
you got to be able to talk shit about
things whether you are able to do the
thing or not interesting okay you can't
play that role because i need to get to
then you couldn't say anything about
anything i hate those curtains have you
tried to knit a curtain i have which is
why my curves are so shitty i have a
very low i bet those are woven okay i'm
like yeah that's why i let them be
little well fine but it is yeah i but i
love talking about movies because it to
me when you're talking about movies
you're talking about yourself in the
deepest things you could never reveal
you just don't know you're revealing but
your real question is why do you judge
people on their movies not what your
movie do you like what you ask is how
come when i hear a movie i'm like i hate
your movie i get defensive because i
think when somebody because i think that
when someone shows themselves to you or
says like oh my favorite movie godfather
i'm always looking for an excuse to
leave
uh accuse
say this isn't gonna work so when
someone says my favorite movie is so and
so i'm gonna go oh well i knew this
wasn't gonna work that's your favorite
movie they're psycho they're crazy a
little bit too you know what i'm saying
because i feel like if i say like my
favorite which i used to be really
embarrassed by anytime my favorite thing
and someone doesn't like it i
immediately think oh so you don't like
me you don't get me you don't understand
me and you don't understand how how i
move through life and you don't want to
and then i get defensive and i'm like so
you know we don't you don't fucking like
each other but that's not what the game
they thought they were playing no i
thought we were just talking about
movies and then it's like oh we're
talking about you
i didn't know that's what we're doing so
that's what no country for old men i
didn't realize that was what was
happening i think we all do know though
really i didn't i think everyone watched
me realize this but i think everybody
knows that they love a movie or a song
or something for a certain reason and
they know everyone has the connection so
i think it's almost like the zodiac
where you feel this certain way this is
the way that i can see something shitty
without somebody really knowing you're
talking to nell
i didn't know that until right now jody
foster movie yes
deep cut and i didn't know that because
when when i'm having a conversation with
someone about art i think we're just
talking about the art i don't go oh
we're talking about you're trying oh
you're using they never are it's all i
know but i'm not i'm like i don't do
that and i get in these meaningless
fights
talk about choose your battles which is
the definition i think of success in
relationships is whether you're going to
choose your battles or not that's it i
truly think it's not about compatibility
it's not about it's about whether
the person yes and you like the person
enough to go you know what i'm gonna let
them have this one
yeah i mean it seems like you might have
some issues with these people outside of
like
if they say they like the godfather you
get really i don't think no no no i
don't think yeah you seem like you lost
a relationship because they loved no
country for all men there might have
been other issues there it's it's didn't
lose it's when i it's when i slept with
someone else that we lost it yeah the uh
movie they made me do it yeah so as oh
sorry as the joe and renon talk movies
uh co-host
um and as someone that i really respect
on your opinion on movies i'm going to
bring up a movie that
i know is going to i know this is going
to either ruin our friendship
or just set me off okay
the movie that has
caused me the most angst and that's why
doesn't say if i like it or not well i
just want to talk about it okay
real quick because there's a couple
movies that i wrote down that i was like
let's discuss these movies the big ones
were fight club no country for old men
and
this next movie i'm gonna bring up
i i do know that the director
wanted couples to fight over this movie
okay i'm obsessed with this director his
name is uh david fincher it should be a
dating show one of the greatest and he
said my goal for the movie was for
couples to fight in the car after the
movie which now that i know once i found
out that was his goal
godspeed you you succeeded
gone girl
now
i would like to know your
thoughts as a film aficionado uh slash
comedian two most observant brain types
hold on okay i did watch it with john
lovett
and not lovitz the podcast love it yes
um and
i had never taken an edible before this
was when it came out five years ago i
took an edible like cookie
i don't know if it was the cookie
that made me so the sugar i hadn't had a
cookie in so long or whether it was the
weed whatever
but i was asked to
leave the theater
um because i was so
flabbergasted by the i was which i if i
was sober i probably wouldn't have acted
that way you told me this yeah all right
the that is the key to a friendship with
whitney cummings i don't know we've had
this conversation i don't know but the
job just for about you have to leave
before after they showed his penis
i was so stunned by the casting like and
this is david fincher 101 i'm still so
stressed out tyler perry thing right
right i got in trouble because tyler
perry came on as the lawyer and i was
like
[Music]
do you guys see tyler perry as the
lawyer because that's what i see and i'm
just a little p because i was like why
would david fincher he could fast cast
anyone
why would he cast tyler perry to play
the lawyer of ben affleck
tyler perry played a lawyer in every
medea movie i love how you say i got
kicked out for being flabbergasted i got
kicked out for screaming like an insane
person
i was victimized for having an opinion i
was trying to confirm that everyone was
seeing the same thing
as someone who was cast as someone that
loves tyler perry it's a weird call well
it's like an offbeat choice but this is
what you're doing you're trying to
really
you're trying to remove these
distractions
you're trying to ruin movies for
everyone else in the theater i'm just
saying you see the actor but i'm just
saying that every casting choice feels a
little like like
if you're casting tyler perry you wanted
people to go oh that's tyler perry as
the lawyer whereas most directors
especially like david fincher like like
the mind hunter i didn't know any of
those actors you cast the person that's
going to disappear into the role tyler
perry doesn't disappear as a lawyer and
that's just tyler perry right and then
you turn around in spadina you're like
wait a minute i know i was like i was
like okay big swing it's a big he could
have got anyone and here's other things
david fincher could have got anyone
chooses tyler perry so this must be
intentional you're trying to like wink
at us or make it campy or like
there's something going on you're you're
you're meddling with my
my um
edible patience
i just don't i think you've lost
suspension of disbelief on any degree
of it i almost forgot he was in the
movie yeah well that's what we're
supposed to do you're supposed to forget
about buying into the movie i think
that's really cool that you thought of
it because that i'm like that about some
things but not that i don't think i i do
not support
yelling loud noises
done
[Laughter]
then
we continue in the movie and just when
i'm like okay he cast tyler perry i can
suspend my disbelief i'm in a movie i'm
in the ride
great now what i'm in i'm in i'm
believing that ben affleck is like
dating i'm in
then
the the guy the serial killer
no who's the straight
murderer
no okay the stalker who's obsessed with
the beautiful woman yes who can't wait
to fuck her yes is the one neil patrick
harris
who is yes yeah but he he plays weird
creepy role like that really good
i feel like he's kind of creepy
yeah
is it because he's gay could have chose
anyone
could've chose anyone i'm just saying
after the tyler perry thing
it's a little fishy were you shouting
out this guy would not do that he's a
homosexual
you would not be attracted to her it's
not even about his sexuality off screen
it's like the guy from how i met your
mother
is the murderer like there's a lot of
people you could have put on screen that
you go oh that's the creepy guy i'm
going you forgot the guy from glee i'm
just saying he like did you see him in
versace show that's terrifying
the audacity
i'm gonna cast a sitcom star forget his
sexuality
his sitcom started that my brain is
trained to go hahahaha silly goo silly
guy
to now he's a rapist who's like i'm just
saying you could have gotten a one billy
crit up you know what i'm saying so what
i go is i go this is when a director is
really trying to you know it's like i'm
gonna do tyler i'm gonna hire all these
comedy actors to be in this drama
and your association with them is
hahahaha lol but i'm going to put them
in these really like
that's how good of a director i am
is that i'm going to juxtapose these
people and you're not even
you think i'm not gonna think about how
i met your mother at all
or do you want me to very confusing and
then i go the casting of roseman's pike
the one roseman pike the great roseman
pike who is so brilliant in that movie
and everything after that and i think in
real life
got dinged for playing a crazy woman in
a movie so convincingly that people like
oh she's crazy i mean she has a
reputation in hollywood for being crazy
it's like
or was she just amazing in the movie you
dumbass right so
then at 30
years old whatever she wasn't
stunning she's like i have nothing left
except this man it's like i'm just like
cast someone who's older and really has
or
based on society's social construction
uh really doesn't have any option i
don't buy that that woman's only option
is to kill him and like terrorize him
forever and then my brain goes
after that
to your point about the message of a
movie everyone's like told you that's
how women are
and you're like no no this movie was
meant
to like
crystallize every man's worst nightmare
yeah i didn't actually i mean i loved
david fincher like zodiac i love that
movie i didn't like gong i think i read
the book first and i think it's like an
interesting idea but i think the twist
is goofy and it's kind of set up as a
more real story and then the twist is
just like the fact that she's pretending
to be someone else the whole time and
she planned it all out just i didn't buy
it honestly because to me but to me this
is where movies get important
i know i'm contradicting myself a
million ways any guy was like
well that's how women are you're like
huh where's other people going
well women get driven to this or or
maybe
everything david fincher does is
incredibly intentional to fuck with you
i to me it's kind of like um and i've
been fucked with and i've been thinking
about this ever since he made it but i
uh
yeah i i never like i mean i think the
movie's interesting but i think it's
like the twist is just goofy like is the
movie's supposed to are you supposed to
leave going like that was a good movie
you're supposed to leave like because
when i do stand up i want people to
leave thinking about something never
thought about before like i've never
seen it that way before or like having a
joke they can then go tell to other
people the office and then they get to
be the funniest person in the office
like i have goals when i do stand up
that i want people to leave feeling a
certain way or having a certain thing in
their back pocket whereas like
like when i leave a movie i don't know
how i'm supposed to feel
i think it is love
i don't know if you see movies can make
you feel different ways i mean i think i
personally think and this is why some
people are like
oh you love that movie it's so dark for
me feeling anything in a movie
is important like to me the movies i
don't like are the movies that make me
feel nothing yeah yeah i feel like
michael bay makes me feel nothing yeah
and that's why i don't like those movies
if a movie makes me feel sad
or any kind of emotion the fact that it
made me feel
is something i think is really effective
so i don't mind if a movie makes me feel
sad i'm kind of
i think this is about art in general i'm
kind of happy to feel
anything anything by art you know i
could talk about movies forever because
you're really just kind of
you're revealing so much about yourself
and the more the stronger your feelings
are about a movie the stronger
you see something that either
triggers you or reveals something about
you and that's why i love it yeah movies
are great the show a lot and you
remember cliff notes remember when it
was like you didn't have time to read
the book but if you just read the crypt
cliff notes you seem smart that is if
you have not seen the movie watch uh
renon and joe's podcast listen to it and
you can it's like you've watched the
movie even if you haven't yeah yeah no
yeah listen to my uh podcast and uh
also subscribe am i plugging now or no
yes please it's only been four hours
yeah this is what we do here
i can't stop talking to you no it's
great i love it it's awesome um yeah
subscribe to my podcast joe and ron on
talks movies
r-a-a-n-a-n
i gotta you know but uh but also i'm
shooting a special this fall
um
and uh
i'm gonna you know put it on uh i mean
i'm in talks with youtube
but i don't know i'll put it on
something just subscribe to my youtube
so anything that comes along you'll have
and you've been posting a lot of clips
of your stand up on um instagram on
instagram yeah follow me on instagram
r-a-a-n-a-n don't hit the table while
you say it so people can hear you all
right fuck it
what's his name it'll be in the uh the
below in the little info box wait oh
this thing called drop down uh yeah yeah
dropped it yeah r-a-a-n-a-n comedy yeah
follow me and uh yeah follow my youtube
channel because i'm gonna have a special
comment it might be on something else
but ronan is someone that you can repeat
his jokes at a party and seem like the
smartest funniest person there i don't
think that's the highest compliment i
can give to a comedian that means so
much i really appreciate that so
incisive uh so
um
smart clever
like just like
makes me jealous you do seem very smart
when you listen to your favorite movies
i was like oh i should probably just go
never heard these are things that are
played at film festivals where did you
see this toronto but um yeah and you've
seen the emoji
but um so it comes out which days does
it is it drop what day is this podcast
uh
monday
monday at 11 30 on youtube and on movie
mondays movie mondays uh we're on a bit
of a hiatus
because uh
there's no reason to subscribe so you
know when it comes to wait is that
allowed in broadcasting yeah we're going
to talk
well done are we allowed to take
joe's making a movie and it's like a
thing he's starring in a movie and and
so we just took a couple week break
we're getting back on in a week but
too you have 400 other we've done a
bunch i know but yeah there's tons and
then yeah don't tell people that they
don't know you're taking a hiatus but
the next ones you will watch will be for
loose and dirty dancing yes yes we're
gonna do them all and uh because i do
think it'd be great to do a little
segment of like how to understand women
series yeah i'll yeah we'll we'll do
those i'll i guess i guess i have to
start learning but i like it i think
it's important because i think to me
hearing really smart people talk about
movies helps me learn about the world it
helps me expand my emotional range it
helps me have more patience and and um
and be less defensive and it's a way
that we all communicate without knowing
we're even communicating really deeply
and i forget that sometimes i'm not very
touched with my woman's side all i do is
think about feeling fat and take baths
all day so like i'm already this is why
we get along so well
because we have both at the same inner
monologue yeah i've already i'm already
there but like um
uh yeah yeah but yeah this has been
awesome it's so fun thanks for having me
i hope you come back again of course i
will yeah yeah and um the best anything
else i end these like super awkwardly
and don't
can you clearly uh say your instagram
my podcast is joe and ron on talk movies
you're the one who told me to do this
uh it's available every monday
and uh follow me on instagram
r-a-a-n-a-n comedy and follow my youtube
channel to see my new special that will
be filmed and coming out in the fall
unless he takes the hiatus let's retice
um and that's my youtube ron on
hershberg uh and uh i hope you were not
distracted while you heard all these
plugs
and uh yeah and i hope you're not a
munchkin
linkedin this is not the episode
[Music]
[Applause]